mais mathieu pour le moment c'est ouais
ça y est on est en ligne mathieu on est
en ligne c'est parti bonjour tout le
monde
donc on a on est on n'a pas les caméras
on a les têtes des joueurs donc on n'est
pas devenu cariat kiné nakamura en
l'espace de 24 heures mathieu
malheureusement d'ailleurs je sais pas
on aurait pris combien
enfin ce serait quand même toi tu es
sous tu vois tu serais droite toi tu
serais nakamura parce que d'habitude
l'invité jeu mais à droite on m'assure
écart jaeglé sont même pas terrible au
moins d'un vrai tu m'entends moyens ayew
à la cgt entend très bien mais ça va ce
stade nous faisons ça va se stabilise
est inquiète pas je vois la tête d'un
accueil et son beau nom mais pour une
fois je dois dire qu'ils ont vraiment
ils sont bien sûr les caméras mais
normalement celui qui perd si on a un
qui perd on va le voir petit à petit
sombrer normalement oui ils descendent
petit à petit s'est pas caché c'est
fantastique talent autres qui a un gros
sourire tu sais qu'il est là genre genre
je sais pas un heureux
rayonnant est à l'autre et même chez lui
sa s'assombrit je me rappelle du match
de gousseïnov contre carl scène
gousseïnov à la main je me suis dit
enfin il se pend quoi la fin du match
c'était horrible son visa qui est ce que
tu as fait un lien pour qu'on puisse
partager pour cela j'ai des amis qui me
demandent où m'écouter donc il faut que
je leur envoie le lien de là il faut
digérer on voit le lien du stream et le
lien du cs celui qui s'est mis sur skype
ok j'en vois ça n'hésitez pas à partager
un pour qui le plus de monde possible
il faut il faut il faut de façon qu'ils
partagent mais ça ils le savent
enfin tu avais raison de leur rappeler
mais sinon de toute façon ils se font
taper à la fin du truc c'est pas faut le
savoir les mecs les mecs sont en danger
quoi vous êtes obligés de partager sur
what's app sur les réseaux sociaux de
partout ça commence dans une minute
normalement alors un prônera les mathieu
un prono un prono avant match prenait
avant match moi je dirais
mais plus difficile que ce qu'on pense
je pense ça va être chaud je kayak et
des bleus sont bien motivés accents
casque je pense camacho ménaka j'irai
légèrement favori mais vraiment les
jeunes moi c'est moi je pense car yakine
1 depuis le début depuis cariat keane
s'est qualifié je pense que teria qui ne
va gagner mais après après je comprends
qu'il ait pas favori mais je le sens
bien je le sens bien
de toute façon c'est l'algorithme a dit
que c'était un 50 50
ouais donc j'ai regardé l'autre c'est
conséquent bullet il considère que qu'il
est légèrement favori una k way après
pâques les arbres plutôt qu'à yakine en
plus c'est long plus c'est karine qui
mise ce qui est pour moi c'est bizarre
parce que je pense qu'il est moins bon
en rapide ce qu'on avait dit le jour
dans la vidéo bon ben ouais je pense
qu'en fait 5 + 2/3 plus de vrai ça va
être en faveur de mes tracés kohl's
voici comment ce produit 5 plus de 6 à 5
plus depuis trois plus depuis wimbledon
lui importe que ça mais un plus un tu
vois c'est pas du 1 0 j'imagine que pour
dextérité d'un car moi alors j'ai
l'habitude de jouer en bullet et c'est
un ca paris sûr mais avec le second
c'est moins important je pense que la
différence
ouais ça reste important mais tu disons
qui peut pas te flag est comme une brute
comme comme i fé large président a déjà
joué vite contre lui sur internet j'ai
gagné c'était déjà arrivé
devenant le prochain je joue très très
très rarement sur internet donc je me
suis mis avec à la pratique d'ailleurs
mais heureusement pour moi c'est du
rapide et pas du blitz bon j'ai jamais
fait repenser title chose est vrai que
me mène d'ailleurs mais j'ai pas
l'habitude encore mais le truc en fait
c'est ça c'est que n'a qu'à moi qui
l'ait déjà joué en 3 0 bon il m'a
massacré un mais il ya quand même une
partie je me suis retrouvé avec une tour
de plus et là j'ai compris qu'avec une
tour de plus et 20 secondes à la pendule
contre naka c'était impossible de gagner
en fait parce qu'ils te près move to et
je sais pas comment il fait mais il
anticipe tout les coups en fait et tu
sais il te met les petits échecs au
moment où tu t'y attends pas enfin il
est très mal a en fait quand
pense qu'il va te mettre échec mais pas
échec quand tu vis bien s'inverser
jean-emile à tour là où tu penses tu vas
mettre ton mois pour éviter son échec
ils sont perdre 1 du prime au csssae en
fait il fait le choix ils te change
après le coup d'après tu bouges ton roi
là c'est à ce moment là qu'il va te
mettre les chèques il est insupportable
et donc et donc ça en zéro c'est chaud
mais en plus ça en fait c'est pas grave
fatal temps tu joues ton coup ça va tu
tombe pas non c'est intéressant
affaire à suivre donc là ça devrait
commencer c'est ça ou ça a du retard
pour ses finances
[Musique]
non ça va pas démarrer mais ça va
démarrer
ça démarre à peu près à l'heure
normalement et 1 1 qui demande en chat
tu peux mettre à partir en ligne contre
la coque est en fait le problème c'est
que j'avais pas enregistrées dommage
enfin qu'on avait fait quatre parties
mais je n'avais pas les gens à sigean
n'avoir eu sud de hong lei songez à la
chaîne en anglais avant il aimerait
retrouver ça en fait la fameuse j'avais
une tour de plus je l'avais pas
enregistrées c'est dommage après ça a
été mieux c'est elle avait gagné ce en
ayant perdu le sait pas non mais tu vois
je l'étais assis chez moi jouent à naka
qui est connecté tu vois je clique
défier bon tu vas tranquille tu as faim
jeu des filles comme ça tu as ce défi
pour défier tu as su le dire mais là le
dre quatre sets mais je crois vraiment
qu'il aime jouer ils aiment blitz et met
d'ailleurs moi qui connais un peu le
haut niveau je sais que son problème ce
point je pense son problème c'est qu'il
aime pas assez le jeu de haut niveau ils
s'ennuient et il travaille pas assez et
cette année on l'a pas vu motivé
pourtant c'est quand même intéressant de
se qualifier pour pour les candidats way
connectant les dames à ses 50 ans a
commencé ça commençait donc tonton tu
étais intéressé par le répertoire
mathieu dans ce match ouais mais bon un
système de londres ça me fait bien
plaisir parce que c'est ce que j'ai joué
en trois tiers sting à la marche pas
d'ailleurs est ce que tu vas le rejouer
ok mais ça c'est la ligne que j'ai joué
très récemment avec les noirs et les
blancs se comprend des kakis achat a été
introduit par sow ceni d'intéressant
faut 3 c'est une souligne la plume du
jeu c'est fou j'ai 5 mai sous le iii
c'est pas mal aussi
et d'annoncer cette c'est pas le coût
principal principalement c'est fou des
six les deux cas l'idée c'est de
mettre un cavalier sur icade g3a cette
thématique donc ils empêchent ils
l'empêchent tout simplement qu'ils
avaient des f4 quoi mathieu si je
comprends bien et c'est ça après la
pollution est intéressant en général les
noix vont faire [ __ ] suisse rock après
faut toujours faire gaffe à pas se
prendre un caillou 5 accueil auquel 5
tout de suite donc c'est que pour
s'accaparer un stonewall way or ces
thématiques mais il ya une partie de
reach ou qu'il a gagné 107 structure et
nous semblait que ce n'était pas le plus
malin pour les pour les noirs mais bon
j'imagine qu'il a d'autres idées ouais
ouais après après parfois ils peuvent
aussi être surpris nos outils y
connaissent à chaque fois tu pensé
joueur du standard ne connaissent pas
après ce qu'ils pensaient avoir ça
aujourd'hui
j'ai regardé nos jours les parties de
kayak une ambiance il joue quand même
seulement des 84 donc c'est pas non plus
impossible
après est ce que c'est réfléchissons à
ce qu'il ya un intérieur à la dénoncer
cette plutôt que font des six pas clair
la réponse est de facto non puis un juif
ou des six mais bon est ce qu'il aurait
quand même fait dams et 7 dans la foulée
ou pas c'est bizarre auquel à un des
plans connu un de basse et jean recueil
des trois frères scott pour échanger le
fou de quatre mois avec l'idée de jouer
contre le fossé 8 bien sûr c'est en
train d'être joué
et avec les noirs un des plans mathieu j
mali c'est fou 17 faut 8 x h 5
oui bien sûr mais en génie après la
question c'est où il va mettre le fou f1
à ce qui le met en g2 ou pro moment j'ai
deux oui l'ami ans g2 d'ailleurs est-ce
qu'on peut jouer avec v6 fois ci j'avais
justement te demander mais je ferai tout
rond à ça me scie ce faible donc je te
prie nous ferons est ce que vous
regrettez à la case au 4t nakasuga
peut-être éventuellement même tu vois
pas lancé fou prend des trois frères f4
ou cavaliers aux 4 qu'avec a tenu qu
être calqué là je peux je fous rires cas
je pense qu'il faut prendre les trois je
prends décision d'un média ouais pas mal
pas mal on devine on exclut pour le
moment on est on est dans le tempo
journée un tempo du match mathieu on est
deux ans
ce qui me fait un peu peur en ligne
d'après on décide de me prendre et 13,4
je pense non sk stratégiquement c'est à
double tranchant comme si je te fais un
truc comme cali des deux si je t'échange
ce cavalier
pourquoi je serai pas
après pour voir si les papes je me range
étroit mais hier j'ai trois pour le
moment peut-être mais pur point je crois
peut-être cavaliers prend 1,4 voire kf4
des deux pions points et prend 1,4 et
surtout on croyait faisaient cavalier
pour un f2 je m'en aille faut calculer
après aussi faut vérifier d'élèves 4,6
est ce que tu en prends un cas très
mauvais coup je suis même pas sûr pour
jouer avec kg 5 après faut toujours
vérifier ça ouais c'est pas bête ça tout
reprend 4 mathieu bienvenus mais il ya
peut-être d'amd 5 enfin mais ok je peux
encore prendre kg 5
puis on 115 blanche dont 4,4 sur les
coûts non je pense qu'il faut être sûr
ça passant par mehdi visuellement ça
passe pas bien non mais dis le tu peux y
aller on inquiète pas avec moi j'ai
l'habitude je me fais martyrisé à chaque
fois à chaque fois qu'on commente un
truc
dès que je dis un coup la plupart du
temps des façons je le sais moi même tu
vois si c'est un truc je n'aurais pas
joué par exemple lutter ça doit être un
bon coup mais au moins c'est bizarre
mais manquait moi je préfère les blancs
les j'ai passé le thé d'opposition mais
bon c'est encore tout reste à faire le
cake est il est quand même assez
monstrueux donc là il faut avec les
blancs faut être malin et arriver à
jouer f3 dans de bonnes circonstances
et d'ailleurs c'est pas si simple donc
les ihu tour simple on joue ces 4 ok
donc il veut se bâtit veut déminer le
centre en attaque en s'en prenant aux
pions des 5 mai auquel ce qui marchera
moyennement parce qu'il pourra entendre
du puy ont aussi ce donc peut-être un
truc à base d'oeufs qui avait les h4
puis ces quatre comme ça il sera obligé
de reprendre une pièce qu'elles purent
f50 bettini 2 h 4 bon rien avoir à il
veut jouer à chaque écart ya quatre ans
en plus il sent peut-être 100 par tête
de la case v6 un jour on sait jamais une
baisse que voyager si c'est vraiment
moche visuellement je sais pas trop ce
que tu as envie de jouer après des fois
tu dois mes pages et six bolides et
ouais sur aff 5 c'est de faire g5 fermer
quoi mais bon rien de faire mais c'est
marrant parce que sa recette partie la
matu elle ressemble vraiment au scénario
qu'on avait prédit et finalement avec
toi dans la vidéo pour le moment c'est à
dire davantage
ça va je préfère les blancs encore by
megharia king du coup un peu mieux à
khanaqinne un peu mieux qu'ils hockey s
qui dois je crée des deux cavaliers de
francs ici et prépare et f3 un truc
comme ça à long terme qu'elles des 2 tf1
voyage de f3 je te vire et après
j'essaie de jouer sur le pion de six
mois ça peut être un plan un peu longue
tour de hockey ça me va aussi durs 2 to
run c'est d'entrer dans le même plan à
mathieu je me bats je sais pas à tours
soit la preuve que non il va je sais 4
or ce qui me paraît bizarre si à québec
atuq rochette donc c'est du très long
terme ce qu'il fait là il va bouger la
dame probablement où se rendent compte
que son idée était pas terrible ou alors
il nous fait du kayak il sait que il va
il fait rien n'y fait rien pour
l'instant
à j-5 poker lui peuple c'est pas rien
faire mais ça peut être d'ailleurs ça
peut être assez dangereux parce que tu
sais si à la tour qui navigue ensuite ok
mais je comprends son idée mais
gendarmes 3eme et même je crois j'ai 6
ans ils sont fous ouais je pense au
total en fait je vois si on n'a
absolument rien à faire il a décidé
d'envoyer les pions ok moi je persiste à
dire que j'aurais mis notamment le 3e
monde en battant mais là c'est quand
même assez loufoque
enfin il avait la tour pourra enfin il
ya quatre coups il vient de perdre
quatre coups pour moins bien placé ses
tours au final exactement
non on peut pas dire qu'il est
impressionnant pour l'instant j'ai 4 ok
alors st je comprends pas trop tu donnes
lacazette 4 non non mais c'est en plus
maintenant il faut commencer à regarder
des fous prend 1,4 qui peut se passer
son idée à ça c'est malin un peu
embêtant qu'il y avait trois caisses et
4 dames d un bien joué donc là il menace
il faut commencer à calculer fou prend
1,4 tu peux plus prendre la firme
changer et si tu prends le des jeux peut
peut-être et 7e poussé au centre c4 et
puis tu as aussi le plan cavaliers
detroit maintenant mathieu en plus avec
des blessures dans metz le prochain coup
c'est quelle étrange mais je comprends
pas du tout le g4 mathieu g4 ça non plus
pareil je prie pour l'instant moi j'ai
le trou qui les deux sont pas trop dans
le match donc les deux jouent pas très
bien pour l'instant
ah enfin un collectif que je comprends
et détroit tempo bien joué qui sait si
c'est bon mais maintenant je pense que
cavalier va venir vers f4 il va faire le
foot - quatre dont une en reste un
sérieux ou alors tu peux dire en c5
maintenant aussi des quatre il veut il
veut faire ce métier c'est ce que la
bête du tout parce que lequel celle ci
sera loin de l' akazu 4 oui oui c'est
que c'est typique dans les structures
carlsbad d'ailleurs cette idée de r&b
quatre et c5 high command jérôme a
dominé la battue ouais tu fixes le pion
bessengue donc après cas il se sent que
tu imagines sont fous il pourra
peut-être aller un jour en f1 bon
toujours se méfier de kep range étroit
de naka c'est un coup il est capable de
le placer un moment où on s'y attend pas
la cafo qui replace le car elle sait si
ce peut être ok là là c'est intéressant
crise prises laquelle elle croyait pas
trop pour un accord nettement baissé 5e
faut prendre un code mc carthy
d'ailleurs ouais j'ai 1 4
ça se regarde après sa main
c'est tout match ça passe ça non ça
passe peut-être tactique c'est cap qui
comprend fou prend 1,4 intermedia mais
je pense que ça marchait pas il y avait
prise de troie trop courbé catimini les
liens entre 4,5 et une prise de troie
est peut-être le cas il sait si ce qui
traînait enfin deux variantes avec le
fonds en quatre à avoir mais bon c'est
passé s'est passé peu importe il est
mieux en est le cas je ne serais pas
venu là à moins qu'ils aient une idée
compris que je ne vois pas qu'est prix
et six mois qu'ils avaient adoptée de
jeu des 5 alors mais c'est triste et
point aussi il veut je sais de finale à
pascal afin d'amener quatre échecs n'ont
aucune idée sexuellement il prend sur
échec normalement dame croit aussi ça va
arriver des cinq fourchette je montre
pour les auditeurs mathieu après il
reprend ses 6es après l'idée c'est
qu'ils placent une dame en d4 qui
monstrueuse et il peut manger le pion à
5 en fin de ligne gagnant mais ça on n'y
avait pas du tout pensé
le cavaly provicis avec des cinq
lingerie pas vu mais en fait d'un coup
d'avant la tour était en b 5 donc ça
marchait pas il a joué le seul coup pour
se prendre trois buts au passage
ouais mais vous à dire tête ils
voulaient menacé du c4 après peut-être
du coup le c4 bon c'est ce qu'on va
avoir un a sur l'échiquier dam des
quatre échecs vous prises d'abord on va
laisser à bord mais je publie sur des
huit intervenants
donc j'aurais fait échec d'abord il
avait peut-être pas envie du hockey
qu'est-ce qui peut jouer ici mais je
reste convaincu que sa tactique là c'est
je sais pas je ressens que l' avantage
des blancs a diminué en fait c'est un
peu plus mais après oui et les dames
patty va prendre l'a5 je donne ces
quatre jours à tour des 3 karim alors et
donc il encore joël brisse prise tour
des 3 dans l'autre sens soudain 20,4 pas
mal de fans le pion à 5 est faible le
roi blanc est plutôt exposé donc c'est
vraiment une us open peut-être un petit
tour bien pour aller faire tourner cet
échec à six mois
non là il le trouve des trois dents
autour des 3 tu ont des trois et il n'y
a pas davantage faudra faire gaffe adam
36 tours projetteront mais ok et là je
pense qu'il faut que je vous donne des
deux baies vitrées qui
qui trouve un père fait sinon il va être
moins bien à moins qu'ils poussent son
fiancé mais nan parce que si tu fais
c'est 4 à 3 à 6 c'est ce à quoi il y
aura le tour prend g3 non mais tu peux
faire j'en ai nommé deux échecs
tranquille et après qu'eurent il
commence par dale b2 donc on n'en mange
pas de pain bon là faut prendre à 6,1
parce que sinon il y aurait le plus bas
à se faire des tours 1 1 plutôt bien
joué je pense dalle d sinon on remet un
de six tours 7
qui est mieux dans cette pause ces dames
ces systèmes c6 il veut peut-être faire
du tour d 1,3 tout rachat si jamais tu
montes la tour est arrivé aussi manger
ce 3 tout simplement
mais là il peut pas le prendre tout ce
qu'il ya un ace qui peut pas le prendre
nice france 87 ans d'après 108e mathieu
oui peut pas donc ok tour d'essai types
de jeux taurins 8
il faut qu'ils se méfient peut-être si
le roi n'est en danger mais mes tours à
huit ce qu'il n'a pas le temps de faire
trois sur tours à huit est ce qu'il ya
vraiment un match ou pas je pense que
oui assurera j'ai six tours à je suis un
jeune g8 ou ré fuite d'un méchoui
tchèque
tu aurais psychique windows home réponse
bien vu bien damée g8 important oued
alger 8 3 m6 aurait fait ça gagne je
demande à mes affaires wave525 regarde à
8h28 demande de me suite d'un match 8
damas depuis trois-quatre attendez
demain je suis tombé là higgins sommes
tout de suite sur wii mais regrette
turan a mené 4 et dames eu trois matches
à huis seront à chaque iveton j'ai cinq
matches à jouer
ok mais là battant tours j'ai cet échec
sur wife six tours prend 17 et sur oise
six tours 6 et on encaisse adam nuit-là
il est complètement gagnant il peut
jouer la finale depuis on a mis peut
prendre celle ci se prend dans 117 peut
tout échange et puis on prend 1,3 monde
il laisse ça à tours 8
avec ce gamin il vole et à 32 2 avec une
dame a remis ce matin
rien à ma cinq matches et sombres
desseins qui avait demandé 4 m ok bon et
un peu comme prévu kayak in 2000 femmes
dame qui commence à rien faire et pardon
là cette fois de l'acca un peu trop
forcé avec son j'ai quatre tours b 8 et
ses primes tactique
ouais mais après c'est la phase tactique
ça s'est bien passé dans cette partie
pour car yakine mais sap a été propre
propre et à un moment ça sera pas propre
tous les deux parties ok donc ça c'est
sûr qu'il a travaillé pour le match
parce qu'il joue tout le temps mais trop
en glisse ricao oui il faut tout enlever
trop vite
il adore donne et karine et joue souvent
un simple je pense que les deux ont
privé de cette pollution pour le match
auquel je vais te pas te mentir 5 4 j'ai
déjà vu mais je suis pas expert
je sais que ça existe us bank a pas déjà
le fait que tu saches mais ça existe tu
en sais plus ce que quasiment tous les
gens qui regardent la vie dans ce cas
simon soir que carine ledoux a joué
d'ailleurs mais ok mais à cette
pollution avec m
hyper intéressante stratégiquement donc
fief si s'ils veulent changer le flot de
gaza je suis pas sur ses toiles
le truc le plus logique quand on y
réfléchit à ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
fait notre case blanche iphone et
changer aussi qui arrivent à prendre en
c4 direct la new wave et prend tout son
sens si tu as le choix je prends les
blancs je vais jouer mais trinquer en d4
et je les enlève 5
mais c'est exactement ce qui se passe
métal pur ou trois qui est ok prochain
et coups de mer 3 ou 4 5
histoire de mettre la pression sur la
colonne est moi c'est sûr que c'est pas
c'est pas la mort en mai
ok je préfère légèrement les blancs
est-ce que je peux jouer avec g63
j'essaie tout c'est beaucoup trop
dangereux d'affaiblir la colonne f comme
ça à la case f6 itunes je te triple avis
dessus et elle repart à tout moment en
plus je peux te faire un petit coup
d'oeil g3 pour menacer un cavalier à 5
pour me replacer mon cavalier
alors ça c'est bizarre d'un message ça
pour me laisser avec le tempo mais bon
c'est solide et ses kilos mais la dame
en rose cinq centrales ok bon jusque là
tout va bien
enfin je ne faut pas jeter tout rêve de
et à thouars ont pris parce que j'avais
le proposait faut faire attention à ce
passe prendre cavaliers pranger 7 des
randonnées maintenant c'est plus
possible bien joué j'ai nagé 6 mais y'a
pas il n'y a rien non non rien mais bon
ok après maintenant on peut peut-être
revenir et faire le truc on l'a dit à
leur doublé mais ça a l'air d'aller pour
les deux marqué mon match je pense
qu'ils jouent sur un truc très concret
c'est qu'il veut taper le pion de 3 en
force et aura pas le temps de mettre la
pression et il va te coller une tour en
aussi ce qui protégera le cavalier maths
et je serai là qu'ayant des canuts qu il
va faire rage et cette ça c'est sûr oui
donc lie à cassis qui fait lui une tête
déjà ok il loupa pendule heureusement à
tomber un sévère qui joue pour quelque
chose
ce qu'il aurait pu jeux taurins et
attend la 2e tour bessette non tout
bêtement à son tour au 8e jour où à
achat en fait et te dire tu as pape
rhône a encaissé 5 c'est ce que je
pensais un québécois à l'idc key 6 8 qui
attend pendant 45 surtout ses 8 5e
français 5 ha oui et surtout quand c'est
sympa attends je vais montrer ça mathieu
tu es en forme d chaud patate ait autant
que c'est pas mes parties c'est plus
facile
ok tout rouillé là et prend six ans et
qu'il avantage de blanc tomber les
français 5 c'est sûr mais je pense qu'il
veut plus que cette finale non mais
c'est vraiment que ce qu'après tomber
cette annonce est ok roi chien c'est
rouge a dit tout à l'heure donc c'est la
même idée torcé vite ça marche pas je
pense qu'il était assis ma stratégie et
mesdames d66 aussi qu'ils aient pensé
que dans ces quatre seul coup web il a
joué c'était ce coup mais attends là y'a
pas des moins jeunes qui en d4
gd même mantra j'ai demandé si on
pouvait patenté du cavalier c5 pour
aller faire cavalier 17 allez allez
rentrer là bas en force
je pense qu'ils jouent tour au 7 mai
c'est peut-être pas bête d'ailleurs pas
est-ce que ça patine depuis un quai 1 7
5 après tout des 4 1
il prend là pour les y laisse la case au
cut hockey à son idée c'est que toro set
les deux hommes prendront pas bête
j'allais te le dire en plus dans la
vente de tout acheter ses cinq tours
sète avignon prend ses 4 et tu pouvais
pas faire plus on prend à cause de la
tour en 1 8
non mais c'est sûr que les blancs sont
mieux mais j'aime bien il est bien quand
même la cac en plus tu veux pas faire
tous réussissent pour protéger deux
cavaliers étaient attachées avec les
noirs tu peux pas bouger le cavalier f6
parce qu'il est entre guillemets cloud
et tu peux pas bouger la dame 5 parce
qu'elle protège le cavalier c'est chiant
mathieu a joué ça non mais c'est sûr que
les blancs sont nuls
il ya peut-être est-ce que ces gagnants
tu as peut-être même du tour b 5 à un
moment donné qui peut arriver qui peut
tu vois ouais c'est ce que j'étais en
train de me dire ce que c'est manathan
tomber 5 des 6 tours j'ai cinq manades
kf5 j'ai envie de te dire c'est
probablement une menace est-ce que sur
tourbe et cinq tours tours b s'avère
d'être un bon coup tour 17 aussi de
façon logique mais là il jeu local toi
tu me connais mieux que moi mais il joue
trop vite comme mais bon après c'est son
style mais j'entends bessin c'était
peut-être gagné en deux coups a déjà
tourné cinq là au moins ça gueule un
pion tomber sa famille à torby s'il ya
tant pis si sa bande ont d'ailleurs
trouvé six gagnés c'est pas bon donc
mais ça gagne 7 oui mais qui a joué à
cinq cuvées ya touriste mais tomber ça
gagne peut-être mais alors la variante
la dont tu parles va il fait tomber
s'ils s'inquiètent en mai si c'est
hugues ghenne le pion et après tu prends
et tu reviens donc déjà il faut que le
mec se fasse pas maté ce qui est déjà
chaud sur cette affaire car la liasse
cinq noms même internet sont extrêmes et
c'est soit il était peut-être que tu
obligé d'aller en dessin pour pouvoir
interposés sur la 7e mais c'est là c'est
la crise tarde le curé vii et c'est
mauvais signe qu'eric est bon il
centralise en voilà attend qu est-ce que
faire sur d'arrêt cette tourbe et sept
du coup il veut faire dame
non il aura kameni g5 maintenant il faut
pas oublier qu'il défend super bien
ok donc d'un point 3 ne sera pas une
menace qui ratait même si ce matin donc
est-ce qu ici on peut pas jouer de
l'america pour le juge une finale mais
mesdames f4 dame prend 2,3 quand même à
mes amis en 10 mètres et si ce match est
pardon pardon pardon matches à venir
chez ici tu ta droite juin coup comme
d'amener certains qui menace rien mais
qui garde les options mais mesdames des
ses statuts de la tour des huit non mais
qu'est-ce qui défend bien car yakine
quand même nom mais l'oeil acquis 6 6
avant tout reprendre la même fuite ben
justement jeudi qu'il défend bien mais
cas ici si tu veux être faire n'y a rien
non j'allais dire il y avait peut-être
dame us dame e cat et tout mais non il
ya même si c'est tout ces six adieu à y
réfléchir
qu'est-ce qui ça il a trouvé surtout
processes damas fuite mat
il ya peut-être encore camélia kath
cavalerie katy a forcément un truc qui
peut être même d'amener ces matériels et
win ma ma fille ça marchait pas mes yeux
qu'il va faire qu'il va tomber il a de
façon non mais tu peux tu peux je damage
4 la tour où c'était encore en prison
là il y aura pas tout processus que ya
la tour eiffel qui passera ensuite fait
cavalier h3c la même idée mais attention
mesdames h4 se passe quoi du coup dans
damages qui doit gagner comme ce que
j'ai 5 tu peux tout faire tout quel
point 5.7 à une crise au pays en dommage
car le semblable
alors mesdames à 87,1 quel point
d'avancé c'est ce qu'on disait je suis
content
bref 3 eyes des fonds simic oui bon ok
les g5 le retour non kg 5 maintenant
j'ai à quel point 5 km h 30 au quai
bonne partie de ma qu'un bon on a de
nouveau cette même position qu'on a eu à
la partie précédente et il change il
change de g3 merkava lieu sans que c'est
bizarrement qui changent mathieu ce
qu'ils avaient quand même obtenu quelque
chose avec les blancs je faisais un tour
sur le forum
enfin sur le chat un chat pour nom il
change non celui normal faut trois faux
des six qui est le cinquième site canam
se stocker sur ça existe en moins avec
les blancs j'avoue aimer je veux dire
dans la première il avait joué j'ai
trois noms annoncés incertains changé
oui j'avais joué tout à fait sage ces
macaques et je veux le bon coup est en
fait sur mon histoire de coups feu trois
faux des six cavaliers ou cinq le coût
principal c'est justice qualifie c'est
déjà une souris novion coup et sort j'ai
six mois j'ai joué cette position donc à
aa3 à oslo il ya un mois ou deux et
j'avais jugé 4 h 4 rue gamble et c'était
hyper intéressant c'est qu'il prépare
pas se mentir et elle c'était le show et
voilà qu'elle elle six mois je pensais
que c'était juste un peu mieux pour les
blancs sans risque mais bon c'est encore
une fois cette ligne tout va pour tout
le monde juste dont josé chèque compris
rien tout petit peu mieux ces genres +0
10 sur l'ordi ou plus des requins
rendent non même genre juste plus en
plus agréable gens là par un peu pris
j'ai trop on n'a jamais envie qu'il faut
regarder des coups comme m6 web cinq ici
m6 probablement à l'image
[Musique]
ok pour vous on pourrait se dire qu'on
peut tout prendre quatre ans des 6es
jeux pour la structure mais peut se
méfier de fois ci sans fin ligne comme
ce qu'on n'a pas marqué une fois
les dames c'est de pas mal f5 maintenant
il omet un truc 1,5 inquiète tourbe et 8
c pour attaquer b2 au cas où il se fait
prendre à eux quatre j'imagine est-ce
qu'il va oser faire rock ça m'étonnerait
pas son genre de tir heurter maintenant
peut-être prendre juge a tu peux pas
prendre g3 ce cafouillage 7 c'est ça il
l'a fait l'afem l5 faisait 6 il n'y a
pas de raison que tu mens ferme pour moi
c'est elle je vois pas la tête il a fait
quelle tête quand il a donné son pion
c'est pas du voyage avaient pas le cas
on voit plus la tête il a les yeux il
est trop près de l'écran
ah oui non il fait une tête bizarre ça
il fait des grimaces de partout ça y est
c'est l'été il y plein de grippe à ce
que j'ai vu c'est bon c'est bien je vais
me dit si je ne comprends pas ça a l'air
complètement débile g5 au caire bon ok
il va faire rager cet orage suite c'est
à dire pour la colonnade bon pas du tout
ces cinq là c'est le festival des
grimaces côté d'un camurat jeunes mais
là c'est cela ce festival c'est mieux
que la partie encore le regarder
là ils nous les faits tout là bas tu as
toutes les émotions qui sont passés je
pense que tu as eu l'émotion j'ai largué
un peu en un courant h7 c'est de la
merde
puis l'émotion j'ouvre la colonne à je
vais faire tout rage suite d'un match 7
g le matin puis en fait chez le
changement d'idée non en fait je joue et
c'est ce à quoi tu as tout d'abord le
visage ya des cons pouces il est qu'on
pense
il peut je pour autant acquis que j'ai
pour ces 4 bon ok je n'aurais pas donné
pions j'aille l'ehpad cas mais pas
complètement bête sur indices et ses 4
avec avec l'idée du leroy g7 tout rage
suite à la bourrin il a pris en équipe
pour jouer une finale
il reprend du cavac façon donc auquel
l'idée c'est que des kings au 50e mais
un truc quand même sain et je me lance
qui avait cinq donc là une menace fodec
adams et de tourbe et 2 donc il faut
quand même paraît sain ok mais
maintenant est-ce que c'est pas les
blancs qui même jugé trop roger 2 way
pour aller mater sur ans pour l'instant
non il ya une menace muet mais bon voilà
si on fait g3 je montre juste un fou
prend puis on prend dame prend fou prend
tout reprend des deux
c'est dommage de rendre son film plus
récurent plus laurent pas dans les
meilleures conditions possibles donc et
b3 j'aime bien moi j'aime bien ok il
faut que les six ne pas juger troyat
dame prend ça ces pièges ciplic ok
peut-être tout comment tu peux passer le
tour sur la troisième tu peux peut-être
pas injuste okereke la vrije juste
chasser le fou auquel et blanc sont
mieux il ya comme un crime plus sympa on
est mieux développer en entreprise et
no3 et pas beaucoup plus faible que le
roi de l'ace as qui peut jouer un coup
comme d'un mètre quatre ici attaque un
pion et peut-être poussé certains jours
vous ne pouvez pas s'en empêcher mais là
en fait sur hassen qui veut faire tout
rage suite et a déjà beaucoup de mal à
éviter damage de maths
oui parce que j'ai travaillé en tandem
défendra donc fou j'ai six fois chance
que j'avais proposée il n'a joué jolie
mathieu ouais bon après c'est un peu à
double tranchant une manoeuvre comme ça
c'est réussi je te fais le fou 17 ha non
mais maintenant je te fais à 5,5 dans le
bon tempo et le truc c'est que sur à 5
tu fais quand même fois je sens que
j'imagine et donc la grâce à un jeu
flash 1 - f5 clé ok donc maintenant il
faut que les blancs remettent trouve une
idée avec leurs cavaliers b3 s
composerait tour d un cahier des 4 août
alors on pense qu'on peut pas jeu de
dames des deux lacs j'essayerai
profitèrent et après je vais ramener
manqué en d4 maintenant 1 et te dire
c'est moi khattak
mais ça paraît logique ok j'ai toujours
eu en premier façon d'amener 2 tu peux
toujours le des fois tu peux les garder
ce genre de coup tu peux les garder sous
le que mesdames m2 c'est sûr c'est un
bon coup donc d'année de sa toutes les
caractéristiques du bon coup tu tu
enlèves de l'ajax et tu protèges a tant
fait sur puce tu veux plus ou moins
inciter le mec à faire quelque chose si
tu veux faire être 4 - tôt quand il
prend d'abord abbaoui je suis j'ai pas
pensé mais c'est hyper logique qu on
prend maintenant la peau rentrer ouais
colonnes ouverte pour la tour sur
tourcoing fc acteurs par ex un accès
moins deux fois 6 ha oui mais je pensais
qu'il y avait donc je vais me répéter
une dame des deux as tu fait d'un mètre
quatre as assez bien joué mais ils là il
va prendre tout de suite parce que
n'arriva pas performant et maintenant ok
donc la qualité sauf que il ya deux
pions et d'admettre 4 et jouer il faut
qu'il cherche la merde il a raison
l'embêtant c'est bien c'est hyper bien
joué qu'elle des quatre ans ken est
quasi menace peut-être de bouger la tour
et de faire du cavalier aussi c'est un
moment donné notamment et l'aurait donc
vous prendrez quatre pions prend l'idée
c'est qu'on pourra pas faire dame prend
pas ce qu'ils radâmes c7 et le
m'attendais à découvert pour le foie
shing mais qui est mieux là c'est une
bonne question
j'ai essayé de faire torah je suis tout
on n'a pas du tout le temps de faire ça
je pense tu veux pas aller de ce côté là
ça me ferait peur de m'occuper de mon
peut-être mais bon pierre je peux faire
j'ai quatre jours et là je me demandais
simplement fou prendre les quatre temps
reprend f5 et est-ce qu'on émeutes ce
que si on est pas mal
je mangeais incluant - n'y a pas d'âme
c'est est ce que tu as dame elle
contrôle toujours et peinture ok tout
réfutons moquer c'est la même idée mais
juste là je pense est allégé cup
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire tout
recettes que j'ai quatre allers-retours
recettes il va aller où avec laurent h6
tu penses mouais j'ai 15 4 il donne 30
des quatorze hommes se seraient en cause
chaud chaud chaud chaud
séparés c'est le genre de position on
est dix mille fois moins fort que les
deux joueurs là mais tu sais surtout
recettes roi je suis peut-être faire fou
g6 et je me lasse tour avec sept matches
après je suis s'il allait faire ton
prend il le fait dans ce sens non ouais
mais c'est vous même et si les tours
prend pions prend et finalement il ya
rien relève de les protéger pour le
moment donc cette année aussi
en gros ce pour quoi il peut pas faire
de me prendre les cas 2007 allait donner
à voir un math devait y avoir un mal
là-bas je peux pas si si il y avait un
matt williams et sept sur why fuite dam
des 8es après 2 me soit par cette dame
h7 damas je suis dans la voiture repart
de l'autre côté pas de maths ouais nan
bien vu mathieu donc les blancs sont de
nouveau mieux d'hommes d2 il a entre un
vrai bon c'était pas le meilleur timing
ouais donc il peut pas trop bouffé à 5
ans compte aussi un macaque quand même
ça va calmer
ok je pense qu'on a qu'un vol a indiqué
le fuji 6 bizarrement je leur place
règne en f3 perso il mettrait le ranger
dans notre flash mais en fait tu le sais
tu avais raison c'était bête d'échanger
une tour il devait faire un chèque il
faut aussi strict mais c'est la règle de
ou l'oeuf anderson je passe tu connais
le volant d'une règle non en fait c'est
dans le bouquin de dax elle s'immisce du
fou on en reparle quatre ans fait ses
dents pas dans le panneau foison c'est
dans l'autre et il dit que en fait si
ton anniversaire il a deux tours et que
toi tu as enfin dans les déséquilibres
matériel en fait tu veux jamais échangé
la pièce on quand toi tu en a qu'une et
que l'autre en a deux genre si tu as une
tour est un fou et l'autre à deux tours
c'est quasiment jamais une bonne idée
d'échangé les tours en fait parce que
lui il a une pièce qui peuvent de toute
façon faire la même chose et toi c'est à
plus de flexibilité en gardant des
pièces différentes
grâce à une logique de 9,6 bien joué
parce qu'ils n'empêchent les blancs de
faire ce qu'il veut
[Musique]
j'ai du mal évalué
monastir segat c'est trop tactique je
pense en fait pour réussir et vanessa
c'est hyper concret jackson is legal ya
maintenant l'évaluation de leur dit je
te dise que l'ordinateur dit non
j'imagine que d'hommes 3 et il va
trouver une nulle mais je veux quel
ordinateur diffus g6 et avantage quasi
décisif blanc + 1 50 oui mais fou
justice et psychologiquement c'est dur
pour lui ils viennent je faisais chier
en fait il te dit que les blancs étaient
mieux amellal et les blancs sont très
bien d'après leur dis mais là ça devient
plus dur la d1 donc c'est bien plus dur
en fait il faut juste sans doute qu'ils
avaient des idées que la tour s'activant
rentre donc ce qu'il fallait faire ces
maîtres seront à l'abri puis après
comment ça allait grimper les pions way
mais le rejet a en fait le l'ordif des
rois gerra après il ya trois pions pour
la pour le truc hein j'avais vu que deux
mais comptez donc là il vient de donner
un pour jauger 4 puis donne des cut
il est un peu en tilt o'kelly des
sections en adam il prend le large et 5
qui prône autorise prend 1,5 donc liés à
l'eau oui tout ça c'est un jeu de hockey
c'est peut-être encore un peu mieux
probable en mai or le temps ce 30
secondes contre 17 chez moi il ya une
proposition de nul et ça a été accéléré
ok vol
encore une fois les bleus ont dominé
bizarrement c'est hikaru qui a proposé
ballet ok il a souffert toute la partie
quand même ah tiens ils jouent à carnac
in jusqu'à vlad m'avait recommandé de
jouer contre b3 justice
j'ai vu des parties de jeux baba sur
cette position c'est qu'il disait contre
un chantier tôt le fj enquêter dans le
rôle du roi était souvent plus fort que
le chien kétou du côté halde a donc du
fait que le mec est joué j'ai trois en
premier c'était hyper logique de béton
en premier c'est hyper logique de jeu
une variante avec g6 en fait non
c'est clair c'est logique mais ok sa
puissance et 4g méline fout d'eux ils
maroc et m faut faire gaffe à casser
trois pattes le faire en faire même mais
bon est-ce que tu passes le fou d'abord
à dessin est servi ok il laisse un rendu
fou on peut faire un bep six faux
bessette b6 trouvé cette c5 ici mathieu
ou sait jamais adams où ça c'est un truc
de fou il veut faire tous ces cinq faux
prince tout ce truc de fruits mais
pendant un bout comme v6 et un coup je
dois me à 10 me on se prend à hillary et
là il a fait une grimace n'a qu'à aller
y est ils se concentrent il se rapproche
de l'écran fait quand il calcule des
tactiques mais y'a pas un truc de
contrefout in avec fou prend dame prend
fou prend à vii pour preuve cette dame
français 5 et cavaliers 17 enfin deux
variantes et ils encaissaient la torah
en maths
oui j'ai vu mais il faut compter le
matériel avait pris deux pièces et tour
contre la dame
les deux fous et la tour et je t'ai
entendu pendant 1,5 en un pardon donc
les pins banon parce que toute façon le
fouillis ressortir en mangeant quelque
chose quoi quand même curieux ponctuent
mendy pour vérifier en fait j'ai pas
vérifié mais tu peux j'ai pas regardé
mais tu peux mettre lane dans dans les
coûts de la partie à droite en fait t'as
évaluation et ligne et tu peux mettre
rhône sur lines et tu peux regarder
visiblement la pression était passif ok
mais il a regardé il a dû penser que ça
a marché mais tâter à la fin tu perds à
un état pas assez de ma table ce que tu
arrives pas l'enfermer manners bon ok
c'est quoi cette position alors c'est
typique anaqua ils visionneront il aime
bien les jeux les positions stériles
comme un surtout sur internet j'ai
remarqué jeudi qui met la pression et
hitler patients mc2 pourquoi je sais pas
tarquini là un gros sang froid quand
même parce que le truc avec fou c'est ça
qui l'a calculé hyper vite aussi un mine
a peut-être eu la chance on pense qu'il
a pu rater bas principalement toulouse
est ce pas mais bon si ça marche pas ça
marche pas quel fou ces cinq jeux
fouquet les noirs n'y a pas de raison
qu'ils sont moins bien mais bon les
blancs non plus tout va bien pour tout
le monde
j'entame 17 août 2006 jamais mes joueurs
de jouer ce genre de position mais avec
aucun des deux noms a écopé une pause
non j'ai toujours mal joué ses positions
c'est pas toi y'a tellement de pression
j'aime jouer et pas de règles mais ça je
joue encore beaucoup moins bien en blitz
quand longue en longue je réussis encore
plus ou moins me démerder à ça il a
l'air heureux la naca est identique à
une pièce là non il faut le 5 encore qui
ce qui est nous voient déjà datés
plumieux déjà témoignage aura prince
comme fou des cages québec at ma 12h15
des cat eyes le jeu d'un même si ces cas
d' abandon aillleurs d'ailleurs voit
l'avenir dans syrte ans de partout la
non megueni lé biais subban ok je trouve
l'idée
sa c5 maintenant mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que ça va pas ok ça il n'avait pas
vu ça ils l'avaient pas vu une ak on
voit son visage il n'avait pas vu je
regarde le pain est également en train
de danser avancé 5 l/ha est complètement
dégoûté mais jeudi il a il a de la
chance parce que nakai il a aussi raté
de genre je gagnais pièces et finalement
c'est pas si clair mais il ya aussi ceux
pensant mais c'est qu'il a fait
maintenant il se passe quoi surtout
prend aussi soin yahia darryl willis
encore les quais hennessy accueille des
six comprend g6 et pas maps mais sagan
et parce que j'ai deux mots s'il doit me
prendre et 5 sont roger sautent des
tours 6 dan des huit ça doit ça doit
tenir parce que du coup il ya tour g7
qui peuvent intervenir surtout reprend
g6 ouais mais j'ai le droit de bouger
mon cabinet mais pour aller où est ce
que j'ai appris du cavallino c'est un
artiste de la défense mais on n'y croit
pas une seconde
dams et quatre sur sept mais il mérite
de la perdre un seul un pour être
honnête j'ai besoin qu'il a rien vu de
la partie il a essayé de tenir un parti
qui défend il voit les idées de défense
des immigrés de cela prendre ma relève à
cela je vois pas iliad hamsik est taxé
caso prochain c'est fini qu'est ce qui a
un coût il va le trouver mais qu'il
prend des cinq dames c4
j'échange les dames et ont cette finale
et peut-être pas su se gagne pas non
mais gers et gagna
ce qu'il ya plus simple dames ces quatre
essais cet exercice mais me tv5 avec
l'ambiance se marrer carrier qui ne
rigole y ait roulé des chances il est
content de lui non mais c'est quand même
impressionnant parce que nous on aurait
abandonné depuis longtemps mathieu way
ou alors on aura dépensé deux minutes
pour trouver des coups comme il l'a fait
parce que là il lui reste encore 2040
il joue encore super vite les deux mis
en ligne cette position allait mieux
mais il faut qu'ils la gagnent encore
normalement ça devrait aller a su
toujours vraiment impressionné par par
les défenses de karuïa keane son fonds
de commerce
ouais non mais tu vois ses juges trouve
que peut-être les gens se rendent pas
toujours compte quand ils voient ces
partis en fait parce qu'il fait jamais
rien et c'est pas du tout spectaculaire
en fait de défendre mais c'est quand
même incroyable de réussir à faire jouer
une position aussi venant pendant aussi
longtemps c'est la dame 1 pendant qu'il
va commencer à faire des petits échecs
remède à moins 5
ballan mettez un peu de toi est ce que
sur le sur le long du match je pense que
ça peut jouer psychologiquement
physiquement de sortir des défenses
comme ça genre même si tu la perds est
ce que c'est un impact ou pas du tout ce
qu'ils veulent faire tilt elle je sais
pas l'accueil en a vu d'autres quand
même moi je sais qu'un mec qui me
défends comme ça ça me rendrait fou qui
l'a fait dames 1 comme on le sait
il va faire dame c3 après quoi que tu es
tu n'arrives faire dame prend qu'avait
lieu 4 amené le roi e5 courir c'est sûr
c'est ce qu'il va faire après et
normalement ça doit pas suffire mais non
mais ça c'est complètement foutu mais tu
peux toujours prendre une fourchette tu
peux toujours te prendre un truc tu
crois le gars il commence à faire la
course ça peut être pénible ton mais
3ème étoile à 5 mm
quatre cavaliers défend les deux pions
et c'est chiant et gagner dès que tu le
fais jouer à la tête d'un mauvais coup
mais peut-être pas kenchil peut-être ces
quatre mains un c'est quand même pas de
mettre à couper soit 5e mais si tu
attends là roi des cinq au québec
fairway f3 fait qu'elle ait des amateurs
ce qui va les attendre
eise temps débutait bien et il y aura un
exemple qui a poussé des coûts il l'a
fait dans ce sens pour pouvoir jouer les
essais 5
je suis pas sûr un second tour bessin
qui a essayé 5,3 des deux tu vas te
faire et quoi que roy ces six affiches
et j'aurais fait l'échec sur la
cinquième personne paris tu fais pas ça
me rassure plus d'avoir les mêmes
réflexes que toi qui es mêmes réflexes
que n'a qu'à en fait bizarrement way et
on glisse camus non mais il est beaucoup
plus fort et tout ça mais je pense que
je sais pas si je fais plus confiance à
ta technique quelque part après c'est
sûr qu'il serait plus fort parce qu'ils
calculent beaucoup mieux et qu'on peut
pas lutter face à de tels joueurs mais
je fais plus confiance à ton instinct en
fait lorsque tu veux dire mais ok la has
en ligne de 4,6 là qu'on veut pas que
quatre essais 3 qui veut pas perdre je
veux faire c'est trois cavaliers c4 à un
moment donné qui est donc là il
pierre vial et jora pourquoi passer
quatre d'abord juste pour narguer
peut-être ces catégories way 10 à ceux
c'est juste bête de ne pas avoir fait ce
soir parce qu'il aurait fait on plonge
de 5 il aurait fait rêver 4 c'était la
même position sauf que là tu lui a
laissé une chance de jouer un coup en
plus après peut-être que le pouilly
mauvais tour je suce moi ce qui me
surprend aussi qui joue tout impôt tous
les deux alors qui mais là ça doit être
gagnée pour les blancs quand même un bel
est complètement ce qu'il te reprends
des cinq heureux de nom mais c'est
étrange d'avoir le peut-être qu'il avait
vu quelque chose sur ces trois fait
qu'on n'a pas vu mon cheval a pris 0 à 2
et c'est fini
quoique peut-être faire trois ou quatre
et sur roi des rois des trois améliora
g5
une fois que j'ai ressenti beaucoup mais
je te remettre ouais mais c'est hyper
bizarre ne pas voir je reprends entre un
héros bekale sur un court arrêt c'est
fini roi des 3 et revient c'était
important de le jouer quand même
pourquoi des 300 ok donc une masse sous
gestion voyons mais à présent c'est
serré mais c'est vrai c'est un peu le
mauvais scénario là si on veut un match
serré parce que si forum en fait le truc
est dommage c'est qu'il est pas gagné
cette partie numéro
3 ou les complètement gagnant qu'il
rejoint la ville est ce qu'il va faire
j'ai si cette fois non ils rejouent
alors le truc passif alors il s'était
retrouvé moins bien parce qu'il avait
donné une pure afsset bêtement ouais
mais bon ok la pression on pensait que
notre mais bon c'est toi ça joue et un
hockey ce qu' ils hésitent pour jouer
vous offre 4 1 et un petit changement à
venir avec le cavalier va faire le dam
des deux fois f4 j'imagine ou dams
al-ayyat qu'a t-on que tu peux patrons
flamands date dame sénat mais à mon avis
il va juger 3g 3 fougeux deux fois j'ai
fait quatre bons mais la vie c'est ça
son île kg 4 dans la guerre qu'est ce
que je veux c'est tournicoter avec le
fou genre foucher 5-fu h4 fou g 3d je
faisais hockey de toute façon ici tu vas
faire j'ai trois fous j'ai deux fois f4
donc il met une fois en c1 pour le
moment cette façon il reviendra en f4
ouais c'est bizarre mais bon même évoqué
le 5 juin jour cinq ans mais bien jouer
un coup comme fou seul mérite est puni
il va tout changer sur re5 effet refusé
2 ok mais l'ailé nord seront pas moins
bien ils vont maintenant des habitudes
des cas c'est ce que je vais dire il va
se débarrasser du pion il va débarrasser
du pur isolé et puis et puis ça va les
lui
on imagine celle aux possessions dame
prend des 5 tu peux passer sur suis tu
vas te la [ __ ] en c3 de façon à la
rigueur pour faire ça mais bon de toute
façon tu peux pas ne pas le parquet
rapidement mais la tour des huit rock et
des quatre essais
ok c'est juste égal ouais probablement
pas de raison qui quoi que ce soit après
ce qu on peut aussi se dire les blancs
seront quand même mieux fouiller de long
terme qui ont 17
souvent on peut ici donné que l'on
baisse est pour contre attaquer son plan
b de faux j'ai cinq intermédiaire mais m
il cherche la merde cherche un peu mais
pas bête foule ou trois maintenant jetés
milles plus loin et si c'est ce que tu
es content non du tout à part ok ok mb
3way dam des trois îles pauvres et au
pire y fait prise prises des adhérents
et bach pas un nombre qui a fauché
quatre une tour d un hiatus fongiques
est bon mais attends là on a vu que je
peux de jeu puis on prendrait quatre
vous prendrez cut grand mais là on peut
peut-être faire juste fou g4 avec les
noirs et je te prends mais tu fermes
auxquelles il faut à 6 je dois prendre
b2 reste d'être c'est juste égal mais à
la fin tu as à 7 qui traîne
ok les blancs sont un peu mieux mais
léger sur nice paris grand chose et
infligé quatre semaines au cemat hockey
ou l'ipad y écouler garde cette je
voulais menacée mais bon comme je façon
tu fait d'armes français car ça ne
change rien je pensais le jura je peux
juste 3 de beaufort h3 d'avoir ça peut
être un peu hein c'est quoi leur visage
là ça lui donne un kayak si elle a
content c'est bizarre j'aimerais bien de
voir la verra bien voir la tête de
de naka s'ils se rendent un peu de maths
mais bon malheureusement c'est pas
arrivé
j'aurais bien aimé voir ça sa dernière
sortie il inhale lna oui il allait
mourir
oui il a les nombreux tirs ok l'idée
c'est que tombent les huitièmes au
prince est donc je tour 2008 n'a pas
trop envie bon général ainsi de pulsions
je vois un faux de fous des trois et on
sacrifie a et b pour récupérer baissé
mais en fait ça c'est exactement la
variante que je regardais enfin que j'ai
calculé et je me disais que c'était un
peu pénible d'avoir les deux fous
braquer mais bon t'as dit mais même
peut-être juste tour des sept noms mais
c'est juste que tu sais pas comment tu
vas bouger la torah 8 à cause du plan à
7 c'est ça
14h07 doit jouer comme tout rose pas
comme tu as envie de jouer mais le
problème c'est que h trois hits mais le
font eux deux en d3 mais avec les noirs
ont peut-être à 100 ça m'a non non ça va
pour le nord savoir en clairement pour
la voir ouais assiste maintenant comme
ça en vous je la tour et puis après on
est assis c'est pas le coup qu'on a
envie de jouer encore une fois mais
c'est peut-être simple le plus simple
après c'est au tour des huit après y
aura foule et 6 dont tu me laissera pas
vraiment trop de buts mais bon faut bien
ses lacets cariat kinder qui a très vite
jouer mathieu on s'en est pas rendu
compte mais cardiaque il reste quatre
minutes
pourquoi pourquoi tout d'un coup décidé
il ajouté
le tour c'est 8 ok donc ça c'est typique
n'accueille veut défendre activement sur
moi c'est de faire tour d2 j'imagine
tout bêtement fait un tour à lui les
deux surtout prouvé saturent à tour ses
7 qui enfilera ouais il faut 3 poule 3
c'est pas fini la ligne vos droits en b2
et après tu as et trois qui traînent on
sait bien jouer il ajoute des cinq qui
les jugent jouer et qui déchoit 3 2 b 4
ans non merci je fais jamais des trucs
qui vous moquez tour c'est un an
continue il va prendre des tours détroit
est ça qui est du coup ça va pour les
ça va pour les noirs pas ça va il ya
encore des compense largement
ça doit toujours être aux alentours des
gars non cellule noir de trouver les
coûts mais euh ok il veut garder sur
l'apple c'est ça et en plus il est bien
élevé parce que tu as les deux favoris
qu'ils contrôlent mais moi je pense je
devrais je n'aurais jamais laissé le
pion à la purée d'avocat ou trop peur de
hockey à 4,5 et ses attentes en ce crime
à 6 grimace grimace l'image de ce qui
attend français trois reprises christian
6 et 4 et la finale et sans le perdre en
tant que je prends de la tour ans et
catch attack g4 je force les changes des
taux avec l'étoile avait gagné à tour et
c'est un bien jonathan est un monde qui
n'importe quoi je vais penser à notre
jeu
est ce qu'il peut faire [ __ ] en c3
vous prendrez trois pions prendre je
vais en 8e dire non ok mon trop mou mais
si vous me lisez ce que je veux je des
fous de leur poser tom waits mais en
fait c'est salaire d'un salaire d'être
le mieux en fait ouais j'ai envie de te
dire non à cause de fous des quatre ici
mais non mais le fou s'est vite défendu
la torah oui également je vais value et
donc ils déjouent wiseid tempo quand
d'autres auraient créé des deux donc
pourquoi on sait rien d'un des deux il y
avait faut prendre les deux vous
prendrez 2 ans et 8 ans bégu de cloche
il voyait les trucs les mecs m
ouais pas toujours c'est la différence
qu'est ce qu'on vit ici avec les mains
d'un 4 luc tu fais pas et après ok
imaginons tu fais des deux je peux
toujours faire tourner ces trois fonds
prend des deux mais faute que leur a
posé il va mettre un x en étroit et
marées le pion à je pense pas qu'on ait
assez pour gagner
donc à moins qu'ils trouvent ici un truc
de fou ok h3 j'aime bien l'idée il veut
dévier le fou
soutien et surtout à 3 il veut que la
maison soit loué c'est ça que le fou
soit clouée je comprends pourquoi il
prend autour des 1 c ivey en 9.5
simplement f3 hockey fouet et du coup
voilà qu as des as en fait ce qui lui
fait dans l'autre sens et sur tourbe et
7 après fou prend des deuils aura tour
des huit qui cloue c'est ça le truc
ouais je commence à me dire tu en prends
g7 for lashes tour des huit mais il ya
de ça donne quoi ça peut y sont avec les
deux fous ça doit avoir cette confiance
pour épurer acte ii malheureusement il a
l'air de tenir la naca après c'est
compliqué et ça pour être malin il est
malin c'est son fond de commerce et j'ai
trois as tu fait fonctionner sur l'île à
monastir sousse et de gamme
ok il peut aussi jouer genre en j2ee
contre ce 2e tour en d2 et je sais de
finale et les gaz
target 1 dont la même plus compte que
c'est que tu as l'air mais d'abord et à
la fin c'est juste et galway et vu le
scénario la partie je sais pas tu aimes
te faire l'arnaqué à force
je sais pas ce qu'ils peuvent qu'est ce
que je ferais g4 mais il va faire c'est
vert pour prendre des deux nuls
fo ivey pour f5 maths à ça la fée
marraine à carnac à ces marées et il n'y
a pas un chien
j'aurais jamais fait ça va être
compliqué ça masque à tout moment il
attend d'elle qu'elle est très mécontent
naka est très mécontent il ya un truc
qu'est ce qui se passe sur la poitrine
il est pas content en quarts et qu'il
est bien de secouer la tête dans les 2 t
oui j'ai pas dire ma vie un drôle green
j'ai pris un chien quoi faire donc et
kaya qui ne leur sont pas allés très
aller chercher de trucs avec f4 f5 qui
menacent mater tout c'est quand même
brillé en confiance alors tu noteras qui
changent à chaque partie les mecs avec
les blancs et dans l'autre sens c'est
toujours la même la ccar ya kim qui
change de système
balayant ces six là je qu'élève 3 plus
besoin ni magasin cassis et p3 après oui
pardon ça c'est pas le tronçon système
atlas avec le tronc ouais c'est le trois
poisons ça j'ai déjà eu cette position
avec le 3 poison c'est ouais c'est ça
n'apporterait rien mais pas attendre
plus quoi dans le chat y en a qui
parlent que j'ai écrit un livre sur la
rade au dîner la kalachnikov c'est vrai
alors ce type d'opposition j'en ai joué
mais toujours avec les noirs je sais
jamais trop quoi en penser bon ça doit
aller mais au moins ils jouent aux
échecs on va pas voir de grosses grosses
nouveautés un an ce match pas la
critique
là je vais bien je type de position avec
les blancs avec les noirs ya beaucoup de
pièces sur l'échiquier c'est compliqué
tu peux faire des plans c'est sympa -
vidéo 2d général quand tu es le meilleur
tu peux gagner mais après quand
tellement bon tu peux aussi accrocher
les mecs parce que ses juges sur un
jouet pour les noirs une petite erreur
tu peux te faire glisser
ok dans l'absolu je préfère toujours les
blancs ce d'un temps de plus mais c'est
clair que c'est la plaine du grand chose
dans la question est-ce qui on est ce
qu'on prend ses 4,6 me willy quand j'ai
l'impression que si on prend c'est quand
on est un peu moins bien mais c'est pas
ce qu'on attend d'eux plus on acquiert
est ok tour ça c'est les piles pour
effacer la dame aurait ce que je fais
souvent ce que j'allais dire ton c'est
cette dame a eu les tours c'est limite
souvent pas mal comme plan street qui
dit ouais mais j'ai remarqué que ça
marche beaucoup moins qu'avant ça paraît
bête cette phrase mais je n'ai pas
c'était un truc qui marche et dans
l'entre-temps souvent celle là en fait
maintenant je trouve qu'il veut je
beckett prendre de l'espace al-dam bon
normal mais tu peux te laisser faire et
mettre le cavalier le cac est là il a
pris ok donc l'idée c'est que maintenant
qu'il est france dès ce 4 2 ce que tu
avais envie de faire maintenant il ya
d'hommes 31-13 il ya une jambe et trois
reprises à cause du quiz mais tu peux
prendre non tu peux prendre du full tilt
points tandis que les battre a obligé de
prendre du fou mais il fait quand même
damas huit et du coup il aura peut-être
le temps tu vas te faire tour des huit
dans le bon tempo pour attaquer la dame
est placée du fou car tout l'arc pense
pas bécade le mien ce qu'elle est c'est
toi qui es prendre de 6 en garde
ouais mais regardez la tête mesdames
c'est de fou et 4 dames ces trois
cavaliers à quatre noms italiens ben
ouais mais ces dames un cavalier à 4
quand même peut-être accueille des deux
du coup obligé de me calmer
ah ils jouent sur le clouage de la tour
maintenant oui et cavaliers à 6 pourquoi
pas mais peut-être qu'on peut faire
mieux
pas sûr non qui clôt et ouais mais je me
disais peut-être pour prendre des deux
avocates et les jeux wii est ce que
faire quand des deux équipes mais le
bouillon il est un jeu comme elle s'en
fout des cas tu peux prendre en d 2 km 1
il est en train de brûlots l'anac a eu
mille bouillon est ce que tous se
sentent sur france 2 eric 1 c'est un
truc dégueulasse comme fou ces trois ça
peut survivre ou pas c'est dégueu mais
l'idée c'est que je veux plus avoir mais
remarquez il va juste ce qu'il faut
c'est trouver la juste quoique
damphousse et 3 yake prends ton prend
temps prendrait de notre enquête
ouais pour ces deux retours ce2 ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'on est moins bien et
inquiet pour attendre dans l'oeil a un
coût maniaque et métro aussi qui peut se
regarder ton français seront sacrifiés
il est en pro d2 tam tam et 3a tu peux
pas il ya d'un promoteur du coup faut le
mettre dans le bon ordre à peut-être
encaissés sur calais nord sens mieux
mais juste il faut qu'il trouve le bon
set-up ce qui est aussi j'ai 2 1 qui
traînent en faut pas l'oublier il ya
tout qui traite de partout peut-être
cavaliers à quatre avec l'idée surtout
français c'est dark et prend b2
la réponse est 'oui' m'applique à turin
cette emprise qui traînent sur la fin
mais peut-être qu'on peut simplement
faire qu'elle prendrait reprise prise et
on bouge notre carré les gens maintenant
camélia kath est en game menace la paix
prend b2 fois ci c'est on ne vous prend
de donne ma chance il va faire avec il
vient à eux quatre ça c'est surréaliste
ont connu un passé juste empêcher son
projet deux c'est juste waouh
ok il est il est toujours bien mais faut
être trois maintenant c'est légal tu
sais juste et car je sais pas s'il a
raté quelque chose ou par l'institution
j ai aucun doute il a à revendre je sais
pas quoi non mais toi typique de trucs
qu'on avait dit dans la vidéo
des fois il se contente de peu aussi
elle a tout échange est content tu vois
la caméra est très heureux et j'ai tant
quentin bryce au monde en tout temps les
yeux de temps en temps c'est comme fab
en fait et tout en heureux allait
proposer du très très heureux dong rim
et c'est la cas qui est dégoûté en fête
d'accueil complètement épuré de la
partie alors que carla qui très heureux
mais c'est peut-être sa force aussi à
kariat qui attire 1,4 à un gt gt life
met a été inactive pendant une heure
ouais un classique c'est simple ok donc
c'est exactement la partie qu'on analyse
et l'autre jean louis avec le plan et
karelia 3 qui a été deux ils valideront
choix de raison qu'ils pas de jaloux bon
c'était quoi c'était b3 food et 6
président 13,8 qu'il a troqué j'ai trois
ans qui est thématique un tueur mais le
foutu contre la casa le cap
ok on l'a vu il a dû préparer une
meilleure idée et cleveland 6 il répète
pas le plan qui a marché à merveille
ok il marqua un lien il va peut-être
faire cavalier des f3 car il y eu ses
deux seins il valait en d3 f3 ou f4 il
veut du jeu comme dans le décathlon work
at il fait comprendre qu'il a compris ce
plan avec le f 4 c'est mieux pour les
bleus
mais quand il réfléchit il n'y a pas de
raison que ça soit un peu probable en
pourquoi faut être un meilleur époux
bessette mes parents c'est quand même
vachement solidaires ça on peut pas en
baissant leurs prix si on est noir
g saint gall ça c'est ça c'est mon à
gaza il se remet la structure pour
offrir ce et prend du cavalier on attend
les prix du café la cage de 4 c'est ce
que j'allais dire ouais ça paraissait
très logique
c'est probablement le meilleur
d'elle-même en bon c'est pas non plus un
mauvais coup en france sur mais à pas
mal f6 g5 1 ils connaissent et requins
il se laisse pas glisser tranquillement
kefu 17 l'as tu fais fou 17 tours et 8
que tu échanges les tours et tout ça va
aller dans ce cas là il prouve bien que
qu'elle prendrait cette logique serait
d'ailleurs où je vais pour sortir le
fouet f5
on avait dit ok h 4,6 à fuji quatre
peut-être tu as quel âge de pain ont
tous deux joué à six médailles trice
prisé kechiouche pour son ensemble les
noirs n'ont ni son renom vice peut-être
pas mieux mais en fait je vois pas une
idée de coiffure du cru y voir le fossé
8 au mois je vais le développer c'est le
genre de parties se joueront contre les
noirs mon jeu kg 6 mois ils vont sortir
leur fouquet g6 et c'est son côté ian va
pas se mentir mais je retiens légèrement
les blancs les noirs dont je m'étais
fois un gap un précédent a pas de casse
pour les cavaliers aussi c'est pas que
si j'ai 100 que c'était très bien mais
il est évidemment ça la pendule en deux
pas de surprise c'est un truc à retenir
ça mathieu way à 48,5 à ça c'est un truc
à retenir aussi il faut se développer
dans la vie il te la fais comme alpha 0
quoi il te dit c'est très bien ce que tu
fais mais un jour la tête de naka a il
sentit l'écran il est parti puis c'est
bon mais parce que c'est dans le chacha
marqué parce qu'à 95 ouais ben ses
cravates tu vas te lettre ajoutant la
tête tu vas aux toilettes tu reviens
tout dupliquer proche des 5 c'est à l
icac
en fait je remarque qu'il sait quand ils
calculent comme un malade il approche
ses yeux de l'écran en fait il regarde
l'écran de plus près je remarque que ça
en fait ils regardent un peu
tu vas nous regarder quel est le temps
ok c'est bon j'ai encore une mine
d'argent en 30 secondes kg 6 bon jusque
là j'avais vu et il faut trouver une
idée pour les blancs si dumas labour
semis les mots d'ordre étaient très
excités de base mais vraiment moi j'y
croyais moi j'ai jamais fait mais bon
c'est fait c'est peut-être bête qui
règne au sein qui jouent la finale fouet
5 ha ça j'avais pas vu ça c'est un joli
coup ce genre de coups qu'on peut
oublier en défense et en attaque pendant
ce faux avec 5 g s'être g4 obligés
d'attendre ce que thorgan d'un x 4 en
fout c'est sûr qu on prend il ya quoi la
mg6 dame g6 maca bois de trucs je suis
ici mais je crois non pas scellier bon
ok tu peux toujours rendre à anna cas là
il a fait une grimace n'est pas super
content hockey et il a promis aux
propositions lieu de 14 kayak il rigole
pourrais quand ils peuvent proposer
l'une un hacker refuse enfin ben un peu
mieux quand même nom un peu tu peux
faire bref c'est trois ou six têtes et
une fois que tu bloques le pire est que
le roi ben 1,91 me temime est ok il y va
du fourrage 3 et mater changer ça lui va
te faire comprendre que à la finale de
droit il ya presque est ce qu'on doit
faire eux aussi s'échanger la finale de
x doit être nul à tours angers
m très envie de jouer pour la finale de
fou mais c'est hyper mail a fait mal
dans ta intro verdict manquée de coup il
a raison d'essayer
c'était un freeroll est ce que ça
j'avais regardé pas mal dans les dents
je pense que c'est un du camp de karsten
muller en fait les trois contre quatre
finales de fou de même couleur elles
sont quasiment tout le temps nul bon il
faut quand même la jouer
en fait j'ai tout sur moi classique
ouais en fait l'idée de fond c'est que
tu touches à rien il fait des cas tu
fais roi des deux en fait tu n'es change
rien
et en fait à la fin si tu finis avec roy
fonction contreras fou c'est nul tout de
suite évidemment nam en fait des cats
totally c'est très bien ça fait 3 des
deux c'est plus malin que de prendre des
rois des deux puisque tu n'es ce pas la
casser cinq mois après la danse ce cas
de figure je pense que c'est nul aussi
d'ailleurs mais pas principe tu as
raison après les noirs doivent essayer
de caler un fou ces sites des cats
ouf attention oups voilà il l'a vu on a
des deux est la tenait par principe qui
fait rien c'est ça ta tante attente
attente à tous qui va s'échanger mais on
sait que karine est très bons pour ça-
hockey est ce qu'il faut pas regarder un
des cadres des trois maintenant avec
l'idée je mets un fou en dessin il je
joue c'est cat et je repasse le roi par
1,4 mais j'ai mon avis ça ne marchera
jamais parce que je tends pêche très
agréable de maintenir les liens moi
j'avais vraiment passé beaucoup de temps
à regarder ça en fait ouais même même si
tu as abusé avec avec les blancs même si
tu as vu ce que tu laisses faire un peu
normalement le fou il va toujours
couvrir ça va normalement jamais jamais
jamais gagné mais bon après c'est du
blitz et tout et tu peux te tromper mais
trucks et ça c'est déjà passé laurent b
ce à quoi il va te mettre le fou qui
t'empêche ok peut-être tentés a4 à b 5
des 4 mai il sera bloqué quand même à la
foulée deux fois je crois et sur web et
5.8 web ou que sa 17e c'est l'enfer aux
pressions
non en fait j'en ai fait foi f1 sa place
pour pas laisser roi b5 même en a hélas
pas des cadres à cause de fouet aux 6,1
mais ça on s'en fout à 2 je feuillette
un ordre stop et 3 mais tu veux pas
essayer de mater la fois je crois
commentant peine un fou fou et de je te
fais tu t'en es roi ces deux fauves et 3
parce que tu as l impression que c'est
presque les noirs qui vont perdre sa
voix c'est une juste pour brosser deux
sous les 3 jours vient oui oui oui mais
c'est marrant parce que finalement entre
guillemets c'est les noirs qui doit
faire nul quoi ok tu fais quoi surtout à
4 x 4 si moi je penses tu fais les choix
aussi
on remettra au roi c'est un beauf ou et
de roye b 3 mois c'est un café chaud ici
caisson pkt changea bécane sur b4 la des
changes tout suspense sa sanction prend
b4 et après au moins à et tu regardes un
hockey en poster un il prouve à les
répéter les coups solides d'un car
jacking comme le cac et prend g5 et tout
ça c'était pas forcément correct mais il
a bien défendu il sait pas les sévices
et autres venaient de force bien joué
non mais c'est ça sa force en plus c'est
que quand il défend il sent bien quand
il doit le seul truc c'est qu'il ya plus
un il faudrait que ça soit 1 0 là parce
que au niveau des partis franchement
c'est hyper équilibré plein sans rien à
dire mais ce qui me fait peur c'est
qu'il est comme toujours à part la
partie d'avant il est tout en lui ôtant
on aurait espéré au niveau du scénario
qui prennent un peu d'avancé en cinq
prises au piège après l avantage avec
leur nul c'est que il reste combien de
temps de cinq plus de ses écrits
quelques points il reste 20 minutes
why c'est qu'à mon avis comme ils font
des nuls rapide lance la première partie
qui dure en fait quand tu réfléchis
ouais mais il y aura plus de parties
entre la moyenne je pense c'est
complètement nul non c'est sûr ça va
faire du jeu ça fait un petit temps de
repos pour autant des cats un peu plus
jeudi où il veut faire des trois mois et
demi après b3 quand il pousse son
calendrier
on sait que je pourrais te faire ou
qu'il faut prendre
il faut être 5 manas maths on sait
jamais haïku c4 perpétuelle faut bien un
nom à la fois et on leur offre des trois
là ok mais roy ces deux maintenant il
n'y a plus d'idées non
freud et sur x 4 j'aurais pu me vaincre
le 4 mai au caire il veut faire foot et
s'inquiète façon tu passeras jamais en
d2 non mais il veut juste fou c4
aussitôt temps et quand il fait des deux
je peux je sacrifierais le fou contre le
plan b pour passer il faut faire des
trois des deux oui c'est sur ces genres
et là tu peux faire des trois mais des
trois rondes si je te fait b3 dans quel
monde vivent à gagner ses jeux froide
tu fais roy d je suis roi 3 et roye b 2
non mais je pense que sur des trois
pouces et quatre fous des 5 pouces et
quatre coups des saints mais je fais des
deux échecs pour apprendre et je prends
jamais de malice et c'est la règle de
century ni je vais jamais réussir mais
ya peut-être un truc de diagonale courte
à un endroit je sais pas non mais je
pense qu'il est nul mais bon ce qui est
bizarre c'est de laisser ça j'ai acheté
la corde mais malte est qui connaît
juste eu à pts 26 tu connais après
mairie on va voir s'ils vont la jouer le
jeu à mon idée avec b3 dont classons idc
il attend food et 5 c 4 1 2 lors des
deux amicaux mais là il veut que ce soit
lui faire fou à 4 est fou des as avec
quoique x 4 il va juste rien touché en
fait je refoule enquête
non mais je vais faire pour apprendre
des trois fûts d1 en fait à utilise
flash un coquet ah oui oui mais même ça
je le fais tout ce que le roi c4 a
avancé 4-3-3 ouais mais voilà c'était ça
excuse mais je ne sais pas je voyais
échiquier à l'envers ouais mais il a
raison tout va changer
oui c'est ça c'est que tu fais rien
c'est ce que c'est ce que je me disais
après midi en fait il défend très bien
passionnant comme d'hab et sur le sida
ias j'avais pas vu ils ont pas une
grosse différence ou d'ailleurs non non
mais parce que karine il joue peu et les
matches qu'il a joués en fait il a
écrasé donc forcément
forcément ça va [ __ ] quand tu joues
peu de partis et que tu en gagnes
beaucoup
alors qu'est-ce qui tente maintenant
mais il en train de réfléchir un haka
mais je sais pas quoi je pense qu'il va
faire x 4 je ne vois pas en fait comme
dans quel monde le foie tacle option b 3
en fait mais il faudrait la case avant
la voilà la meilleure chance de gagner
la seprim ou vais manger le four n'ont
d'ailleurs plus d'avant il aurait pu
faire on reprend détroit quand même un
jour ouais mais en fait c'est en fiche
mais je comprends pas ce que n'a qu'à la
fin c'est qu'il prend pas le foot et il
comprend pas que c'est une fille
d'aragorn jusqu'au bout du monde si tu
prends l'option pas je te fait roi b2 à
il a donné son tout exprès
ouais live atteindre les 3 il a tenté le
prénom vous mangez le faut oui là il a
tout tenté jusqu'au bout
mais bon je vais n'a qu'à un salon qui
braille mais bon il a raison si tu peux
tenter tu tentes donc c'est toujours
plus simple pour après c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu un peu de temps pour le 6 5 le jeu
on considère que c'est pas son point
fort ouais je pense pas qu'il veuille
oui après ça c'est vrai mais je pense
pas qu'il est qu'il est calculé ça c'est
pas le genre de la maison n'a qu'à ça
il rejoint exactement la cote à l'heure
où les blancs avaient gagné c'est la
partie numéro 2 donc tout à l'heure il
avait je souhaite ici s'ils répètent ils
avaient une position un peu difficile
avec les noirs c'est il avait perdu
d'ailleurs après il y avait deux fois
ainsi si si ils changent
ok nouveautés tu n'avais 10 x 600 + moi
ça me paraissait logique tout à l'heure
pour échanger le fou contre le cavalier
moi mais je n'aimais pas trop ça pose
après jetée medicaid et cat
il avait pris deux baies et la colombe
et wayne on savait savait pas c'était
pas folichon folichon
ce qui en avait résulté mais c'est fait
déchirer sa soul party où il s'est fait
et là ya pas deux mais trois noms à 9,3
fuji qu'attend on sait jamais tant pis
et oublie tour de huit pieds six pouces
ça peut arriver qu'elle cinq probables
ouais ok donc là il menace rien mais
d'en mettre trois prochains
et est ce que l'échangé de fou qu'on se
carrer les f-5 c'est une idée ou pas du
tout mais je vois pas pourquoi les
blancs seraient pas un peu chez game
c'est bien sûr mais encore si rien ne se
passe à juste justice
mais la dame a fort on se rappelle qu'
il ait eu un problème sur cette colonne
atteint donc la dame est trop mais note
vraiment l'insa green way peut-être des
trois g7 là de façon mais bon au fond
j'ai quatre peut-être pour éviter
justement la dame de venir en f3 bon il
fait froid à 6 ok il veut g4 jamais pas
parce que je voyais pas ta suit en fait
je peux peut-être je t'aime c1 dames b2
touristes cat tout un truc comme ça
j'aime bien ce coup d'amusant mais ce
qu'il a je pense qu'ils vont refaire
comme tout à l'heure et médecins
français cut ouais sauf qu'elle sera un
poil améliorée parce que les pièces
blanches sont un peu moins bien placé
pour pour ça notamment le cavalier g3
hockey la tête le voyez cette d'abord
ouais mais ok donc là en fait c'est
intéressant il ya des cases pour tout le
monde j'ai la case de 4,6 alors c'est
tout à l'heure mais on a amélioré pour
carrier qui mène à une amélioration l'a
largement amélioré sa d'où il a pas trop
de raisons ne savez pas lire mais je
vais non mais si on veut faire f 5 tu
vois pour jouer sur le pion aux oeufs de
caille 7 5 tonnes d'éclats d'ailleurs
qu'à laisser trop univoque quoi qu'il se
passe sans qu'un v6 je te colle un psy
a4 a5 m'ont pas clairement qu'après 8 6
5 4 3
on a vu les problèmes aussi
impressionnant mais le truc c'est que ça
me semi samso me permettait de mettre
cavagnan et si cette fleur de preuves
sur la colonne f mais oui enfin f5 avec
le recul
ok c'est sage waouh quel ça j'y avais
pas pensé c'est pas mal hein bien sûr
tombe bien il ne rentrait comme tanner
moquer mais maintenant ils peuvent
tomber vite quand même il n'y a pas de
corps pas de contre contre-indication
tomber trois jolis coups trouvé quatre
réponses tomber si ces mamies ds3
alors est-ce que si on fait huit la sas
a rien d'intéressant
ça s'est retrouvé quatre corps métro à
touche à tout c'est une jour de statut
quo mais j'apprends que ces insultes à
tiko légèrement mieux pour les blancs
dans le sens où il peut et menacé quoi
les îles à il a fait tomber 5 1 ouais
finalement f5 situe à il contrôle quand
même beaucoup me contre 4 5 905
est-ce qu'il va revenir à une fuite sous
vêtements cette dame f6 voyez s'il peut
proposer nul ce qui s'était déjà primé
donc et maine accueille j'ai toujours
joué que 2 1 moi ya pas d'idées avec ce
coin c'est juste qu'il veut pour rien
et bien ce matin de 5 ans je pense tu as
le prendre cadeau 2005 et vf quête tours
au quesnoy 11-0 problème
mais bon les blancs non plus mais encore
une fois je précise pour assurer quatre
joueurs à tour à trois peut-être en fin
de round pour à l'idée je te mets à
turin 6 et je te rejoins ton bertrand
ouais mais va faire tomber cette je
pense quand on prend un f5 et attendant
de prendre 3 et on s'est juste un
échange cubain jose 3-2 ok avec ça c'est
juste égal complètement des cinq dessins
que je pensais bien joué j'y avais pas
pensé mais là tu veux je prends le c4 et
après tu as tu fait tomber quatre
peut-être maintenant mon lit de terrain
ouais c'est sûr qu'ils en feront qu on
prend je pense que c'est ce que je te
plains joué tour à 3 et qu'elle sait
trop prochain avec l'idée surtout à
mesquer six tours prend ici sur a36
aller tout un échec assez le beau jeu il
n'y a pas de n'y a pas de faits ya pas
de fourchette qui marche qu il est
capable de jouer à un jeu de hockey on
peut peut-être faire des quatre là
maintenant et du coup pourquoi existons
point est fait sur cavaliers des cinq
super grave on jouera le pion par yves
c'est sa 11e tour est aussi ses défauts
aussi si l'on se force le monde
ok pour ce 6 est ce que tu veux pas
essayer d'aller mater la par barge leur
tour b un tour heureux dans sa marche
jamais ce truc etc et veiller à chaque
banque est juste tombé 5 dans ces cas-là
jours à québec deux têtes et sinon
j'aurai je tombais 500 des 5 était
meilleure sauf si j'avais une tactique
que j'ai pas vu tant de s'inquiéter mais
cette pénible accueille ses cartons
cuisse mais nasrallah tour 3 avait
peut-être faire h4 et puis crée des voix
non mais je tombais 3,3 ce que je veux
dire fu chi ok maintenant ils arrivent
bientôt tomber 5 c'était à il veut créer
un réseau nommé de faire tourner
aversenq ériger trois je pense très
primitif tout revient quand même donc
est tombée cet ouvrage 6 j'imagine
qu'elle est deux à est bloqué à trois
pensionnat qu'est en train de la
retourne au sauna on n'allait pas eu ça
dès le début nous sommes heureux je peux
le faire entrer n'est pas qu'un tour on
attend ne partons pas trop vite en
besogne parce que khariaga jouais bien
je suis papa je trouvais deux mois je
tombais nous ok mais là s il faut
calculer est-ce qu'il peut manger le
pion tomber sept cavaliers le 5 super
joueur c'est super droit super fun je
vois pas de maths après washington
ailleurs mais d'ailleurs et de le faire
il l'a fait mais attend est pourquoi il
faut aussi vite ça je comprends pas du
tout pas les deux joues beaucoup trop
vite
c'est sur la musique ça là bas les
points noirs qui risque gros si il joue
quand même super bien mathieu s'imagine
à la ville est sale à cali calcul c'est
dingue a du coup je dois dire quoi c'est
que maintenant les noms sont mieux non
il ya quelques problèmes
non mais c'est jeudi juste ça pour les
spectateurs parce que j'aime bien que
les gens se rendent compte tu vois
souvent tentant les mecs c'est un peu
aux échecs comme dans tous les styles
bien joué et on saute torah 5 oblige et
des huit tours de circuit et beats est
tombé six cavaliers c6 trato spiric
torsades super bien mon cavalier des
huit tempo derrière il y avait tout vu
quoi attends attends à ce que je peux
pas de jeu tourmente i will poulter
tourner avec id torah possible il est
peut-être un ouais mais maintenant tour
à un peut-être tour un tour point f 6
tours améliora il y aura g3 mais
peut-être qu'il se fait choper la tour
derrière attention mathieu parce que
face à l'alliance écrit il est terrible
de défendre comme ça non plus le
cavalier en saisissant
il ya plus tours france et 5 échecs
maintenant hikaru propose nul il en pls
oui là et qui reprend bonnut mais il a
refusé avec taurin attendant il vient de
proposer maintenant parce que
attendront au grill là c'est quoi cette
merde j'ai rien compris et comment tu
peux prévu pour 7 plateaux de jeux à
turin date je propose une quand tu un
nom mais pourquoi il a accepté
j'ai rien compris enfin je sais papa il
ya une bande qu'on a pas vu mais on a
raté quelque chose
non mais peut-être que j'ai 4 c'est
juste perpétuelle mais un et j'ai pu
l'appeler sont devant moi donc je peux
dire j'aurais bien aimé voir quoi non
mais c'est bizarre cette manie qu'ils
ont de proposer nul des professionnels
je vous la jusqu'au bout ok donc ça je
connais bien une petite italienne gelos
autre enquête et à trois c'est l'ancien
plan je pense qu'il n'y a pas davantage
alors qu'elle essaie de mon avis c'est
pas le meilleur mais mon avis perso
j'avais déjà des cinq était possible
nous faut aussi mais bon il a dû
préparer ce cas kg 4 il a peut-être déjà
ok peut-être qu'il peut apprendre à 3h 8
quand je lève 5 ou d ouais je suis tout
simplement jeu qu'est la casaque quatre
dames m6 mais moi j'ai toujours bien
aimé les noirs dont jours de folie sur
en fait d'un qe3 cas et seedorf est au
début ça a été très long en matière
comme c'était bien nouveau mais je suis
d'accord avec toi maintenant on voit
qu'il ya pas grand chose il y avait
beaucoup joué ce truc avec la 4e année à
3 en fait tout le haut niveau un des
premiers ses chroniques 1 et bizarrement
apporter sa pierre à l'édifice même sort
aux quatre gars qui est ok qu'un seul
nageur ouais c'est après tout le monde
après moi j'aimais bien les idées avec
les blancs je vais plutôt vous g5 j'ai
sacrifié la pièce de leur foi ouais
c'est lille qui a traqué les ce2 je me
rappelle d'un élève un mois qu'il a joué
cet été ça s'est mal passé la part du
constat farhi et bon c'est la cdc lille
c'est solide mais bon c'est pas si
simple après il était sûrement pas
favoris contre safari non ouais c'était
nul pendant longtemps et montre que tu
craques aux besoins
safar là et il est quoi ils et 2006 50
ouais moi mon élève n'est pas si mauvais
enfin il faut pas le dis ce que je pense
qu'ils écoutent
ok des cas 3 je suis donc et la position
n'intéressent maintenant qui est mieux
attendre ces maquis mais c'est moi qui
me suis fait déconnecté ouais one off
line foule deux pas malice des clous
donc là concrètement et manosque et les
1er 5
guilhem pions temps on a pu l'échiquier
autour d'une brigade
non mais tu as raison d'être aux côtés
c'est marrant parce que je faisais des
flèches et des choses de temps en temps
mais il m'a quand même me d'actifs sains
ok donc il menacé kiev 1 cinquième
épreuve 3 [ __ ] en hockey ça c'est un
apport matériel la tour de la tour il
veut empêcher f5 surréaliste encore ok
j'avais du mal évalué cette pause bon si
gentil liliacées s'il ya quelque chose
c'est pas grand chose un parce que tu
étais 5 avec un fou de cases blanches
mais qu'elles sont l'idée c'était ça
c'était maintenant je t'en empêche est
peut-être qu'il aurait dû faire à 5 toi
mais principe puis reprend des quatre
étaient peut-être une menace risque il
rédige à 5 laqué blanc cuit je veux des
simples pour jeu la structure au moins
qu'à attaquer les les plans sans casse
blanche sur l'a62 pions nature n'importe
quoi comme plein avec les blancs du
court la tour très mal place en f3 pour
ça mais j'ai empêche il veut mais yves
jeu pour ces six ans les blancs dont je
bekkat c'est sûr qu'avec les blancs
comment est ce qui peut vraiment
progresser au qui l'a fait bk tu peux
jamais faire b5 tu peux trouver 5 et il
empêche qui a aidé sa du mali à une
l'empêchent de semis empêche jusqu'à fin
du conflit
le contrat tu peux gamme de jouets
hockey est ce qu'il fallait pour tourner
un et s'il veut faire h4 pour prendre un
peu d espace où je ne ferai pas à moins
qu'ils pensent que de l'absence oncle ou
même où le fais mon moulin à eau ou bien
ça fouette 3
ok dati il n'aime pas rien faire 1 c'est
quand même un truc de fou ok mais tu
prends de quoi là je te fais b5 ce sont
aberrants
tu prends le gâteau tour des esprits
prise à la fin y ajouter 5 1 à ilebo
alité truc
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire plus on
prend à 5 à un moment donné au final
manqué les plus protégés au prochain
coup il fait ses quatre c4 je peux peut
être prendre un cahier 17 et tenir la
finale comme temps qu'il a pris ok et
après du feu à six au pire c'est ça
exactement ce n'est même pas aux pires
et peut-être même mieux d'ailleurs ses
quatre occupants et maintenant à une
main sur a6 et puis on prend une fois
enfermés mathieu ces ballons this is il
a joué f3 et quand tu me prends à cinq
je te fais tour des trois ouvrages et de
d'abord à un solide et c'est que tu peux
pas prendre de la dame parce que je
prends prend est la fessé 5-1 tu peux
d'ailleurs la tête des cinq ans des
cinquièmes en milieu rural et qui prend
de la tour mais c'est sain quand même
parvenu naka propose une mélasse et 5 es
tu peux pas prendre avec le pion pascal
à tour des huit qui tombe bien c'est pas
prendre avec la dame spéciale j'étais en
train de calculer des cinq puis on prend
on les blancs sont les noms annoncés pas
guillaume n'importe quoi j'ai du mal à
quelqu'un une rare fois matérielle enfin
digne d'une princesse qui peut sacrifier
alors il le fait wahou n'importe quoi
alors pour pouvoir y sacrifier la dame
s'est pas tout match pour faire ça c'est
très bien ça non c'est un cas qui a
proposé nul oui c'est ça et refuser nul
pour rentrer dans sa hockey bien jousse
un parent est ce qu'on peut essayer
d'organiser ces six créé le pion passé à
mais bon il faut qu'il joue sur la 7ème
prince et qu'il a le roman j'ai deux ans
fait le roi il aura jamais at t propose
maintenant n'a qu'à accepter tempo
pardonnez-nous années honnêtement c'est
plutôt équilibrée parce que si je fais
rien n'y a pas de raison guenec non la
page quand même d'échanger les tout
rouge pour obliger non mais il résiste
très bien quand même c'est pas qu'il
réussisse et que normalement il est pas
moins dans les partis ils méritent pas
derrière juste il n'a pas gagné une
partie gagnante je pense que ça va être
plus intéressant quand ça va s'accélérer
mais les parents c'est bien le match le
moins est serrée 1 5 4
tout reste à faire non mais c'est
intéressant parce que ça joue vraiment
bien et ils sont à peu près du même
niveau parce que dans l'autre côté tu
vois si c'est pour voir car le ced
massacrés fin janvier parce que j'ai des
fois fabien tu vois il est tout content
quand il a fait des erreurs mais parfois
je lui dis c'est pour fédérer a gagné 6
3 6 2 6 1 enfin tu vois ce que je veux
dire alors cette fois il a décidé
d'opter pour un b3 pour 30 et les seriez
donc n'a pas rendu là il y en a chaque
fois il un peu en danger avec 5 il a
décidé de jouer en mode réty donc les
blancs prennent la paire de faux il
reprend lavalas il joue son plan
tranquille de trois nuits s'est il fait
jamais quatre lits fait trois dames eux
deux et après j'ai eu plutôt pour ses
4,3 poison f4 pas mal ok ça c'est le
genre de punition je pense que carey qui
on n'a pas joué tant que ça et j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une ak je vous
souhaite tout le temps toute sa vie sur
internet n'en est rien du tout le temps
ça en fait les hits attaque comme une
brute
g ça passe ça ça m'intéresse
kenner 3 sarah format talk aim hyper
bizarre et le mec il a fait une manette
par un même client des six on est
d'accord c'est quand même pas le truc le
plus naturel au monde
qu'est ce que je peux mal cette position
là comme moi quoi ok qu'est venue de
cinq jeunes tapent à égaliser coco alors
là tu es mal avec les feintes et mal
c'est chiant ces trois noms maths en c3
mais c'est mystique et qui nous dépasse
non mais pas il faut pas non plus dire
dans l'absolu ce qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus forts que nous c'est sûr mais des
fois ils vont jouer des coups moins bon
que ce qu'on propose peut pas avoir peur
de le dire
la respiration ou un non c'est vrai mais
ce que je veux dire aussi c'est que
parfois c'est un des coups qui nous
surprennent c'est juste qu'on ait
dépassé par des trucs aux siens c'est
enfin qui est stratégiquement dans
l'absolu mais si on réfléchit on a deux
cavaliers fou contre de faux cavaliers
les blancs veulent jouer sur gazon
blanche est en général et noir se recase
mois recevra les noirs veulent échanger
les foucades noir et jouer avec 1
g2 qui est mauvais ça c'est un truc de
base de le problème c'est qu'après ces
trois on a les deux fous qui seront
mauvais comment il va arriver à trouver
de justes en cases blanches la pensée
simple faux qui n'arrivera qu'à l'ére 5
c'est simple mais est-ce qu'il peut le
faire c'est autre chose se faire contrer
sur l'accolade à tour qu'ils iraient joe
dimaggio adams et ans ils sont fous
ouais mais y atteint 6 échecs dames
prend b3 alors à pédales qui a validé
cette emprise mathieu c'est chaud meyer
par là que ça commence à chauffer quoi
ce qu'il y aura loupé deux entreprises
de benoît h
ok il avait dû oublier au début qui
avait cette idée mais bon en fait moi je
rajoute la même position avec les blancs
mais j'ai le pion en deçà de ce qu'elle
vit aux cinq dames c'est dedans qui fait
le truc on a dit non tu veux faire dans
bellechasse est ok je préfère toujours
les blancs mais c'est bizarre d'amber il
va doubler ses tours à huit voix si
c'était sur s'était créé 4 voilà ça
c'est bien joué ça je comprend enfin ils
ouvrent ils ouvrent les diagonales
mais bon les noirs c'est soft sont pas
si mal c'est camille père groupe est
bien solide mais voilà la parole vous
trouverez proprement et c'est simple
bien joué donc je vois pas
y'a pas de tactique un fou des quatre
tient tout ouais ça marche il a fait
d'accord et peut-être la dame bête 6 5
et 17 ans et est revenu ce qui veut
faire ainsi 5 des cas tu veux dire ouais
mais c'est 5 des quatre ça où les cases
blanches quand même mais bon c'est sans
céder mais après ça que la tour 1 2 les
gammes pas si mal pour gêner le fou j'ai
noté ouais c'est sûr mais avec les noirs
c'est pas si évident à jouer mais je me
demande si on n'a pas envie de ramener
la dame va racheter car tu vois car dame
des mineurs
rien n'est joué pour aller faire du
damage quatre dames g3 que moi mes
moyens calais 17 qui traînent encore on
fait quoi de ce cavalier décède
finalement ok qu'est née sa
différenciation
il faut prendre ses trois arrêts
kylie bloso comme une bonne accroche on
a position quand même un truc c'est
qu'on va perdre la torah 2 qui est un
peu notre seule gloire
on va la perdre c'est juste un échange
en a380 rien ça va encore peut-être
qu'il va réussir à la neutraliser par du
tour f2 ou quelque chose comme ça tu as
tour ff de hockey il a concrètement il
me laisse quelques congés 4ème sur le
préciser om scalf ou c3 qui traînent en
bout de ligne nokia pas tour eiffel de
pour le moment peut-être que si les
projets 4 x 4 ok il a plein qui est un
truc ont un coût ça se fait et idées
cloud cavaliers entre guillemets leglou
tenu tête de coupable
mais il ya aussi les fous comme torah a
regardé après parce que quand il ya
beaucoup d'attaqués les dames c'est fort
un genre un point le mangent pas khiêm
non je vous serais trop à penser qu'ils
joueraient damas ou d'ailleurs ouais
c'est pas grand chose
non c'est vraiment de la merde cette
position c'est hyper dur c'est un jeu de
manoeuvre j'ai pas quand les jouets de
construction n'y a pas longtemps il m'a
fait cette manne havlat d'un match
cataracte 8 ça m'a beaucoup plu du coup
aujourd'hui de le faire valoir et
j'avais quand j'étais jeune j'avais fini
parti comme ça donc un grand maître
thompson savtchenko dans la baie nonu
j'avais fait j'avais passé madame avec
les noirs comme dans la fuite et sa vie
c'était le coup gagnant
j'ai gagné un truc sur la grande
diagonale un peu ça fait toujours
plaisir
c'est un truc dans le monde le voit pas
souvent quand tu le fais tu es content
bonfils passe rien en face maintien
d'affaires nul bonjour pause j'essaie de
génie il sera comme nuls d'affilée
j'ai pas mais il ya eu une victoire deux
victoires et quatre parties à peut-être
à ça ça c'est nouveau ça c'est dur en
sommes à ça moi je ne veux pas te mentir
je suis pas un expert
par contre je vais bientôt jouer un
tournoi de random pas ce que je vais
faire le tournoi de reykjavik en islande
et il ya une journée de repos avec toi
dom ouais exact alors que je réalise
je connais les règles je me rappelle
plus pour leurs membres malheureusement
là tu fais comme un roc c'est à dire que
là si on bouge le cavalier b8 on pourra
faire un nom peut même faire grand roque
avec les noirs leroy passant ses mythes
la tour en 1 8 et si je vis d'un petit
rock faut bouger tadam et le roi passant
g 8 et le g data on essaye hockey
puisque je pense mais moi j'avais faim
[Musique]
mais j'ai aussi les blancs veulent faire
grand roque c'est quoi ces rois c'est un
tandem oui et tu vois la ligne affiche
d'ailleurs pour ans et symétrique
quand vous savez pas quoi faire en en
fischer thiès en général on regarde nos
fous et on nous l'a relégué ronald des
fous les deux allez les blancs on fait
ça les noirs sont juste oublier joe b6
mais j'imagine que c'est un coût qui va
avoir lu qu'on va avoir bientôt paraît
logique
le truc c'est qu'en fait quand les
pièces sont bien placés dès le début au
rang d'homme ça donne les parties plutôt
symétrique et sèche en fait ce qui est
marrant c'est quand même si elles sont
très mal placés dès le début en fait
genre un fou angers 1 1 autre enjeu
c'est pas mon en d1 tu vois des pièces
complètement mal placé dès le début ça
donne des parties beaucoup plus
compliqué en fait c'est parce qu'il a
trouvé la whey quel point 4k et ce à
trois reprises obligé de prendre des
francs mais c'est marrant mais est ce
que c'est bon c'est un autre débat
ça ne paraît pas très malin mais en fait
c'est marrant parce qu'ils ont envie
enfin dit pas que c'est mal mais géré
par an par un truc marrant mais en fait
le mec vient juste de se doubler les
pions en réalité sur eiffage là c'était
l'été c'était original mais voilà plus
original que bon damien est ok dénonce
mais c'est vraiment ces exodes pour le
foie ut supérieures mais il peut pas
jouer sur le fait que tu as du mal à
pousser b6 en fait un genre si je te
prends et que je fais un dame f3 moment
donné tu pourras jamais poussé b6 mais
bon après tient d'ahmed de pas mal il
menace le pion à cet état tu 3b 8 et sur
dame des cas sont des 6es ya rien qui
est cloué ok peut-être qui me sied de
faire le cadre du cours
simplifier un peu la pause jours après
la provoc et roye b 8 d'ailleurs parce
que roy v8 de toute façon tu envie de le
faire pour relever six pattes à damas
était péter par ou n'était pas soin de
15 et rayonner pas qui va bouger mont
des cats
ouais mais bon après b6 p6t6 écrit aux
familles le fait facilité d'un meurtre
aux échecs avec m
oui c'est ce qu'il va faire mais bon pas
n'oubliez pas il ratera pas une chance
de faire nul acte et cache pas que c'est
facile de trouver la couleur caisse est
ce que ces cinq et un coup c'est une
tour des 5 des maquettes mais ce qu'avec
les visages ou quand même un peu à cause
des pions doublet où tu proposes nul n'a
qu'à il peut la joindre qui peut émerger
d'un mac comme c'est si tu peux même pas
nieuws 84 rue de carouge ge fait doubler
sur la zone euro contre eux je ne te
laisserai pas une pièce qu quel est ton
des six est une idée pour dire tant elle
peut passer mon tour f2 probablement à
tours l2 des quatre amis s'en fout pas
les cartes proposées que je sais des
génisses match c'est un match de gros
génie non mais bon ça non mais c'est
peut-être un peu too much as les nuls
quand même tu vois un petit corps sikhs
and rules
ce serait pas mal là quand même parce
que ça fait un peu too much des
ingénieurs l'autre partie qui était
hyper chaud de la nuit ça m'a un peu
laissé sur ma faim
là j'ai l'impression qu'ils proposent
une tous très vite ouais c'est bizarre
alors qu'ayem pose là ça marche comment
trois minutes de pause même c'est pas
bon qu'on a fait un tiers c'est ça au
niveau tant non non on a fait la moitié
là haut niveau tant à la moquer mais
j'ai pas l'habitude de commenter ce que
j'ai déjà mal à la tête quand je lis
j'ai pas l'habitude tu as déjà mal at a
time est ce que tu te mets à fond tu
vois tes fautes et chose quoi je te sens
je te sens je te sans calcul et de
partout où tu auras tes parents ta son
aile
webb a d'ailleurs fait les j'ai
vachement ml début de match position
intéressante et aux ailes à partir du
moment où c'est arrivé il ya de la cci
chapet un gain il a mis la serrure il ya
dix ans par deux matches nuls
c'est très bizarre ils causent 6,5
hikaru donc comme prévu match serré par
contre qu'est léger avantage icaro non
mais j'en faisais cadence s'accélère
le truc c'est que faut soit que car
yakine est attendu le 3 + 2 en disant
qu'il va faire la différence en trois
plus deux mais sinon il faut qu'il
arrive un bullet avec au minimum +2 il
peut pas arriver à égalité en bullet fin
après c'est les mecs qu'on y perd contre
chansons peut-être qu'ils disent
rendu là je suis pas un moment que d'un
cas il est juste bon son intérieur mais
moi je joue pas sur internet
donc ils savent pas que je suis meilleur
que lui il peut se dire ça le mec
bon je trouve ça bizarre non mais
sérieux après tu as tu a raison de
souligner que c'est des gens qui ont qui
sont très très confiants donc
donc oui pourquoi pas mais quand même
quoi je sais pas ce serait quand même un
manque de lucidité de sa part mais après
c'est tout à fait possible qui pensent
comme ça surtout qu'il a assez bien joué
en bullet dans les autres matches qu'il
a pu éventuellement s'entraîner avec
avec nepomniachi ray c'est possible je
ok ok dans l'absolu on pense tous que
c'est un avantage
un haka d'accéder à caden donc les nuls
plutôt alarmantes et régional k mais bon
comme vous seriez on sait pas ce qui
vous dansez speech aces et n'a pas gelé
et dernière en bullet à chaque fois
qu'il a joué il a écrasé 6 ha non il a
une âme à dieu quand rooney pourrait
tout ça mais il était déjà le match
était fini
donc c'est pas clair franchement auquel
est nul c'est quand même bizarre
des dons ont un peu peur en fait
peut-être bah ouais j'ai l'impression
qu'il se jauger et est certes vrai
qu'avoir match de foot où ça s'était
passé à la mi-temps puis s'est pas passé
grand chose au final il ya eu quelques
petites scories dans les dix quinze
premières minutes tu vois ça un peu
attaqué puis après
ouais ça - ok voilà donc qui pronostique
sous les ouvertures et qui avoue je
pense qu'il n'a aucune raison de pages
web et 3 parce que sort le 5 il a été
mis à chaque fois dans cette ligne avec
le 4 donc j'ai lutté l'heure sur la
forme que le cas c'était la suggestion
de meireles qui dans un livre sur les
dents un niveau un article c'est pas
quelqu'un avait parlé de sa femme c'est
pour ça que j'avais déjà vu passer
l'info avec des cinq dernières parties
je pense que les blancs étaient mieux
comme on n'a qu'à pas trop et quoi faire
non ça serait intéressant de savoir ce
qui va jouer sur b3 dans ce cas rien qui
avait vu l'arrivée des cafouillages
quatre syllabes tenu des positions
intéressantes
après il a enchaîné sur e4 une petite
italienne où là rien eu du tout puis
enfin pu finalement l'impression qu'ils
étaient mieux donc voilà j'ai à présent
dans les ouvertures naka quand même un
poil dominé bizarrement mais c'est très
bizarre parce que quand il joue conte
des mecs moins forts généralement il à
des poubelles et tu vois quand il joue
quand des mecs de son niveau il ya des
bonnes pause je sais pas trop pourquoi
est ce que c'est parce que il prend plus
le truc au sérieux probablement il n'est
peut-être pas montré comme ne peut pas
montrer comment ils jouent exactement sa
team est là il est un peu léger tu veux
dire de je ne sais pas où il s'éteint et
donc du coup non je pense que là c'est
hyper important pour calquer notre api
zone il a besoin d'arracher la green
hill a besoin de gagner une deux trois
parties sinon je vois pas comment il
pourra c'est là ça fait une heure qui
n'a pas guéri de partir alors qu'elle
soit une heure qui n'a pas perdu
mais en fait ouais c'est dans ces
parties au final il ya tellement peu de
parties à résultats décisifs que ces
deux parties qu'il a perdu il a surtout
une il y en a une qui méritait vraiment
de la perdre entre guillemets ouais et
au par contre il avait montré encore des
grosses défenses il avait trouvé des
seul coup de rouge et non américaine de
cela prendrait bon alors on est reparti
comme prévu et il se laisse prendre en
f3 ça c'est comme aller jouer maxime
contre rapporte si je dis pas de bêtises
le gat rapide ça se peut que je raconte
n'importe quoi je peux plus contraignant
que je ne mets plus où je ne l'en avait
plu c'est le march c'était rapporte avec
les blancs bon du coup il refait le
cavalier 8 à rioz ces trois de nouveau
est-ce que des quatre c'est un coup
mathieu ici pour les noirs ouais je
pense pas à cause de ces coquillages te
fais ce t4 est en fait comme si on veut
jouer sur terre blanche ou si tu monde
se fout il venait donc sur des cats je
vais montrer un pour les auditeurs c4 et
pas depuis on prend évidemment
mince j'ai mal cliquer de partout je
vois jamais quand tu mets des flèches
mais non mais c'est pas grave janvier
pas janvier pas très souvent d'un autre
côté je vais bien je montrais ans sur
des quatre c4 et du coup le fou le fou
blanc rayonne hockey par rapport à tout
à l'heure
et comme une grosse forge post a marqué
c'est la colonie il n'y a pas la même
influence hormonale l'autre dans l'autre
côté on n'a pas la case aux cinq aussi
bien que la partie d'avant mais là les
noirs et réussissent à bien maintenir à
14 il veut mettre le foot à 3 c sont
mangés fous ils veulent maintenant un
con
est ce qu'on peut faire un plan à la
dame des huit tf6 pour essayer d un peu
contrit soulac aimions à trois étapes et
un peu sur le pion c3 je pense rien a
lieu cinq des stratégiquement plateau ce
que j'étais là ils échangent des fraudes
camors normal point noir dans les
blanches de ces quatre normales ils
doivent jouer sur gazon d'ouvrir mes
parents il est blanc l'objectif c'est de
rien faire au centre et non pardon non
ne vaut rien touché pour au mur et le
fou g2elab sidam des katas jean louis
nadal de changer d'âme tour b4 reprendre
la case des cats pour s'en prendre aux
pions à castans et n'oublie pas tant si
kaya qui n'échangent pas les dames c'est
que c'est un bon coup et déjà puis en
français quatre à le guen pas de pion
dans deux poules de quatre
il va être en prise à tout moment ouais
de la lidc at risk magazine affaires km
le 5 mai il a raison de le manger donc
maintenant le fou j'ai de vie merida de
sa vanité 5 maintenant est bien sûr bien
sûr et surtout moins du coup tu reprends
de ces et tu vas voir une méga structure
de pions en gros s'il faut prendre il
n'y a plus rien à regarder
il est évoqué ici il faut arriver à ceux
des clous et on sera fixé six pour le
moment qu'il est noir on les versions
quasi gagnant près fin il faut pas
oublier que quand on avait regardé les
parties on s'est rendu compte que la can
n est pas rien faire aussi un parce que
là il ya du lourd ncaa qui va être tout
le temps prise en plus mature je me suis
trouvé comment ce décret de trois pages
autour des 4 ici hier jouer on arrive à
ceux des clous et il va à 4,5
mais c'est un peu désespérant l'os sap à
la tête d'un bon coup ces cinq bien
jolie a du coup en plus quand tu prends
si tu prends sur route et de kerry le
curieux reviendra et revient mais même
si tu prends gsid fait qu'il prend mazda
la pièce qui joue pas
l'otan et ricard ou a continué de
trévise mais bon il a quand même une
cinquante huit événements ça suffit
largement pour convertir st ok là est-ce
qu'on peut pas gérer les requêtes avec
l'ecc avait eu 2 s'est joué après tu
peux quand même faire tourner quatre
mois l'invention d'un prend même prend
s'en fout tour à deux mains ces cas pour
la case fourchette prendre fout pas mal
aussi qui est maintenant je te bouffer 5
après je te pousse de pioncer ça sent le
gain facile et plus et direct
mais en russie un oui mr montre il va
jet tours d2 pour attaquer adam qu'il
fait des médecins centralise tout sous
contrôle tourne plus f5 peut tromper et
dès qu'il prend aussi sujet si je
reprends les gavalda me 5,2 me gâte
choqué c'est bien ce à peu près unam
idée mais là tu as peut-être du tour des
huit tours b un moment donné aussi ces
mêmes je savais que j'avais peu hockey
prend les taquets veilleux 5 au prochain
a lieu cinq s'arrête fort ans a menacé
cavaliers f3 j'aurais bien car il y eu 5
mais ce qu'ils appellent une peau de
banane on entoure des katja dame prend
voilà il joue seul cool peut-être faire
tomber un arbre est tombé
on y disait tout à l'heure me plaît
peut-être un petit coup dachy saint
geours ne faut pas avoir une case achète
et on voit un pardon menace cavale yeux
de hockey mais hikaru ne serait pas
icare ou s'il tentait pas un truc we
know me va déjà je n'aurais jamais fait
ce truc non il le prend d'un f4 voilà
dans ta gueule
tu as l'air content à la quitter pour
des 400 et 4 et qui hélas faut réfléchir
comment elle peut gagner cette finale
c'est peut-être pas si ce n'est faire
cavaliers detroit
si je pense que c'est le foot il va
jouer parce que moi tu meurs et b2 non
mais tu les prends ces cas tu te fais
pas enfermer après cavaliers pros énorme
et il y accueille des 3 la wii le retail
et j'ai pensé à cette finale le tour
mais faute paraît proche de saint
quentin b de tomber quatre ans militari
de pains jacquet et détroit maintenant
je comprends pas c'est nul ça fanion pas
sur ce soit dur mais déjà par là que ça
c'est absa s'approche de la nul ça ouais
[ __ ] si les marseillais s'étaient
déchirés ou on ne peut pas jeter en
bessin parce que je suis dans le car
elle toujours se poser la question dans
la lys à un titre qui est bien placé
pour 25 ou sur ces cons m51
sorede les plans de guerre ici c'est
normalement cette tour f-35 mais comme
il joue et tu auras set c'était pareil
pouvait pas passer mon no 3 on voyage
cinq ici mais ok il veut pas gagner
mathieu cfoot
c'est pourtant le parti typique de trucs
mais bon franchement j'ai f5
mais la question que je me pose c'est
pourquoi il a pas réfléchi à quelques
jours tant il a craqué au moment là au
gai et très bien joué après sa mallette
de cavaliers pour vous faire jeter un
coup d'oeil mettez des fois c'est le
genre de truc il a peut-être cru qu'il
avait deux points de plus au lieu de ça
arrive ça il n'y a pas eu d'appel y
dénonçait le jour mais ok il peut
essayer de faire parce qu'ils aient 20
jours au 17 mai tour herbe ou non il se
prend deux tours est ce qu'il faut
remind bref skis watch quatre peut-être
si non on s'est peut-être pas si simple
en h4
en g3 rabais septembre m6 il va faire
gerber se faire tuer six tours 6 à tours
de 6 ou bouquet très bien joli retour et
600 kg je peux je quelqu'un que snow
temps des 4 4 à 4 mais ce n'est pas très
bien joué dans le sens où dans cette
période la tour et si ça te fait gagner
un temps parce que surtout réussissent
on aurait eu la même et aurait perdu en
temps oui non non je vous reviens donc
là il faut jours au v6 et là il va faire
des échecs et c'est nul tout y est
parce que rob et quatre reprises 4 non
mais tu es obligé de faire brasser 6
nuls à ce si sûr on est loin des 7 8
euros mais un petit coup de tours 5
tu bouges plutôt en b 4 au f4 à gâcher
encore masterpiece vraiment propre ouais
ok ils arriveront craquer on la pousse
ses pions
5 évidemment il va commencer les échecs
non maintenant à 8.8 écart ou en euro
bonds à cesser le scénario qu'on avait
peur c'était une domination et le peu de
banane c'est même la peau de banane
c'est qu'il n'a pas réfléchi d'entre eux
vivent ça ne tourne plus s'il pouvait
jouer un bon tour cavaliers avec deux
points de plus ouais c'est étonnant
étonnant parce qu'il veut rester
beaucoup de temps là pendu il a joué
très vite en ce coup finalement aux
moments importants
ok donc là il a décidé jeudi qu'a donc
testé sur le bermuda donc car on joue
toujours second midam iliki chiper des
cats un moment où j'ai les cadets ils
agissent à l'autre jour d'ailleurs la
même 6 mais c'est sa partie basse et
leurs partis d'ailleurs non dernière on
doit bon d'ailleurs on ne sait pas leur
parti sakai des cats
ouais c'est ça ouais j'avoue j'avais
l'impression que les blancs étaient un
peu mieux dans cette partie mais moi
c'est pas non plus au ban aura le
rapport en matériel et bon après faut
bien placer les pièces mais tu as quand
même
tu as quand même plus isolé est à l'étal
tête à la bonne couleur de pièces à la
bonne couleur du fou avec les blancs un
ami il manque des pièces un peu mais il
manque des pièces de genre un cavalier
ça ferait pas de monde mais en ces pions
isolé ça se défend final c'est à part
beaucoup de pièces car on a bien vu que
même si on dit qu'à et qui sait devenir
défense
on note quand même que caro défend bien
aussi mais bon il n'est pas dans le même
genre c'est qu'il y en a qui pesait pas
si toute la partie n'est qu'un icaro à
tout moment doit jouer un collectif
oui évidemment il craque nerveusement il
peut plus attendre quelqu'un qui écrit
dans le chat en anglais c'est que c'est
guy murat contre les coquines
j'ai bien aimé le gearing murat à ils
sont marrants le tchad y sont marrants
j'étais super killing j'ai une
proposition du nom ok qu'est ce qu'on
fait un des deux tours d2 pour des deux
tours sedan
j'aurais bien aimé être là c'est le fou
en f3 tu vas faire faute de fouet f3
mais bon on va laisser la casse s'est
cassé ça le problème c'est qu'ils
s'activent dans ces cinq consécutives à
w en fait part hier avec des gens là bas
tu as l'impression d'être un peu mieux
après des fois l'impression ça fait
beaucoup mais bon là c'est un peu le
trait dit ouais dame c3 bien joué il
veut s'en prendre aux pions à trois noms
mais là c'est le cas où il les perd
jamais ses nus un régime question d'un
beckett est ce que je peux pas te faire
à b attends je lui de remettre le temps
il a pris la tour blanche 2 je suis pas
allé voir le notre chatte ce qu'il ya
des choses un coup le demande dont on
s'en fout non je sais pas ils écrivent
mais mais bon on n'a pas trop le temps
de réagir ce qu'on est quand même assez
concentré sur ce qui se passe dans les
partis mais je pense aussi tu as pu voir
des gens sont intéressés après le chat
ouais c'est pas mal mais aussi moins de
gens quand on stream sur twitter sur le
tchat
ok j'ai quatre thématiques j'ai cinq
thématiques
pourquoi j'ai trois y aurait des cas
donc tubes à angers 2 voilà c'est la
partie je pense qu'il ya des matches
beaucoup plus dur à après pour dominer
les coûts gérer les matchs se rapporte
tu te trouves aucun vous jamais rappelé
avec le feu on trouve la cour et on
trouve les coups un rapport de youtube
tu trouve aucun cool c'est impossible
c'est n'importe quoi toulon mais c'est
marrant quoi c'est plutôt bon signe pour
toi d'ailleurs je trouve pas des coûts
de ce genre de monde il faut f3 à tomber
ce que va faire un j'aime tourner des
castings mais peut-être pas le choix
ouais mais le truc c'est que tout soit
sur la tour en dix-sept elle protège et
à sète elle protège des cinq donc le
pion à 7 en fait ça à l'attaqué l'origan
retient que je me demande même si papa
de faire 5 des quatre il va pas finir
par la gagner moi c'est ça exactement ce
que veut dire ce genre de truc soit ils
proposent une vie tu sois écart vous je
vous préviens miotto non ok tu peux
faire mieux là c'est quasi sûr tour ces
trois ici quand il va jouer des gars tu
mettras influencé si ces détours à 3 way
mais il leur paraît que c'est peut-être
déjà toi avec les blancs qui doit à
faire gaffe
hikaru et demi de plus à la pendule joue
très vite
ok les prochains goudé blanc s'est
engagé trois fous j'ai de ce billet le
saint qui fait rager 3d carrière
comprend trois apprend non mais tu sais
si ce d'abord il fait des cas tout de
suite
il veut faire du fric ok c'est pas en
corner 20 mai
rien il ya un site huras est tombé cas
de fausse et six pouces et que c'est sur
le bcc sur l'échec dans le qu'il peut
jouer ce truc attendait cette faudra pas
gâcher à tampa bay 5 à la twin n'en
resteront mais bon sur tous ces sites
vous fous ces six pouces et quatre pour
à 6 important c'est soit parce que si tu
veux enlever ça toi tu fais tomber ça je
vais le montrer en bessin en v5 fou des
cinq échecs une médaille à tours 1 6 qui
a nommé tu auras si ça va pas c'est bien
ce que je dis est faux b5 b6 faux f1 à
l'échec en f1 et je voyais que ceux qui
la subissent
du coup tu joues 8 ici ou quoi ouais
faut 8 vous prendrez saint cloud pro f
set c'était déjà un petit quelque chose
pour les noirs avec le pion passé mais
tombe et c'est tombé 5 cm et il peut le
faire dans sa vie passée relançant cela
aussi est il tombé 5 qui nous paie
manquer la finale c'est comme tout
allait rentrer rémy nul alors ça va
aller un peu plus chiante à jouer mais
pas beaucoup plus cher parce qu'une pure
et cette emprise ont roulé tant que le
pion b pas avancer les blancs en fait
ils peuvent à tout moment essayé de
manger des trois pions noirs il revenir
derrière leurs pions et quand tu as il a
avancé après le truc c'est que la toile
est inactif devant exactement
et après on peut avoir des idées de
remonter notre 11 mai date avec les
north va faire tu va pousser le pion
puis faire aussi le pousser en général
et 3 rassemblé 3 6 1
j'étais rla déjà ils viennent donner
votre avis mais bon moi je serai à agen
il se penche au braquet et c'est dur de
faire quelque chose un foutu à tour en
bien j'aurais poussé m mais ce qui va
faire est ok là tu es dans les temps
peut-être prise prise à mascate c'est
qu'on est tombé trop échec jamais faire
à 4 mais le truc c'est que les pions
blancs ils sont quand même pas mal à
avancer ce que c'est pas une cave l'adm
a donné un secret pour apprendre ses
positions que je peux te je peux te
divulgué aux médias un moment donné tu
t'enfermes chez toi pendant une semaine
ordinateurs et tu mets tout les tous les
cas de figure possibles lequel tu penses
et analyses à fond tu faisais pendant
une semaine et après c'est bon c'est
toujours quoi faire la faire rage
étonnant où tu as le temps encore pas le
temps elles changent donc d'après mais
quel rang 8 et maintenant le mec va
faire le tour du monde
ok donc il fait froid j'ai deux il va
faire froid ses limites tour b4 et le
roi va monter il va aller viser b2k a
bien joué a très bien joué avec eux
parce que prise prise il ya la défense
de 1,14 c'est un troisième dans le sens
on va l'avoir d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'il
fait il a qu'un seul mandat c'est le
genre de truc panique dont j'ai
s'enliser paris s'est pas ratée parce
qu'il a plus les îles à il est peut-être
déjà perdant d'ailleurs elle a cessé les
b2 et c un tour aux pions et le pion g4
ces perdants
abel annonces et même perdant tout mais
l'heure où les budgets
il a fait craquer autant voilà ce qu'on
va user
or c'était une position facile un peu
mieux blanc un peu l'un est de défendre
un final étonnant qu'il ait perdu cette
finale quand même puisque ces genres de
finale connu que tu dois connaître plus
ou moins parker à ce niveau là non
hu a remarqué que je la connaissais pas
parker parker non non mais mais bon sans
vouloir t'offenser enfin cardiaque le
mec f1 est censé avoir travaillé plus
que moi et mes films de tous tout
l'accord est censé être
être russes en plus tu vois c'est parce
qu'il a vraiment perdu
enfin ok donc ils rejoueront gueguen là
soit 6 plus malin que le coup d'avant
signal clé qui vient aux cinq ce qu'on
avait dit d'après martin avait jugé cinq
albums partielle jeudi 6 mai le même
plan au niveau visage j'ai l'impression
de karaté kid on est tout le temps
heureux et la crème moins heureux j'ai
peu de temps devant son niveau de
bonheur à l'air de baisser petit à petit
quand même bon après il est très très
heureux mais j'ai l'impression qu'il est
moins heureux parfois qu'il faut
absolument que le cas qui n'ont regagné
ça fait une heure et demie à l'écart où
j'habite il est génial et moche elle
fait de l'avant il s'était fait déchirer
à 4 bien joué ces deux fois qu'il nous
fait cette idée pour ok ça ça ça c'est
compromettant mais c'est intéressant
stratégiquement 15,5 à saucats
je faisais ça c'est un serveur scénario
qu'on avait envisagé un temps tout à
fait car il vend des peaux de banane
final c'est un cahier qui domine mais
qui est beau c'est ça qui domine au fait
c'est qui domine pas tant que ça il et
les ja au point c'est regarder au niveau
des parties où il mais aurait mérité
je crois que c'est 50 50 houssin et
charnay qe2 et l'autre ça m'a fait
remarquer une tête ouais et le truc
le truc c'est que du coup en fait c'est
sur le territoire de domination n'a qu'à
pousser la différence c'est à dire les
fans parti kwa ou de toute façon on
savait qu'ils allaient s'en faire voler
on l'avait dit sur une rue sur le match
tu vas t'en faire voler 3,4 c'est
obligatoire et finalement cessé ses
trois quatre parties qui se fait voler
qui change tout quoi mais bon tu peux
pas ne pas te faire voler deux parties
contre ma casse pas possible il est trop
fort question quel est ton plan pour les
noirs kébé ce kebbe 6 et 8 desssus ce
que j'allais dire et pour les visées aux
quatre dames des jo tu fais d'amd 8,1
je défends manquions non mais c'est
chaud et s'il va faire flouer f2 qui a
une et cisco à 3h 4 attend d'oméga-3 la
tourelle 3 donc y'a pas de soucis trois
dames 3ème et à me ranger 4 d'objets
trop du couscous mais c'est quoi la tête
ce qui fait qu'aucun fernand il a fait
une petite tête la brède en saillie fait
une tête il fait deux tête
maintenant il plisse les yeux ainsi que
4 ou non il à plisser les yeux baissés
n'ont jamais il a dû tout dire très
froid et il oublie que comme il a joué à
quatre les pions sont en prison ouais
non mais c'est important pour eux car
yakine de la gagne et ça la vieille dame
g4 tout est dit de me calmer jamais mais
bien un objet 14 j'avais pas vu dans
madame g4 de baston j'ai vu d'un proche
quatre tours age iii et la dame enfermé
c'est après que j'ai vu d'alger 4a games
vous avez pas vu de base comme j'ai
toujours un temps de retard quoi sur un
butin de 106,6 ample et là tu fais tu
mets ta da mois ci soit écart ailier des
six études ou démissionner ok il faut
regarder s'il n'a même pas une équipe où
il peut jouer si ce coup là c'était
peuple humain auquel aka meyo 400
reprises ok ok tours 7
alors là il faut doubler sur la colonne
mathieu tranquillement et l'a conduit à
perdre un match et la première dame à 3
tours ou turek trois tours à chaque fois
où la houleuse cherche désormais un
déluge et autres on est sisi veut juger
s'ils te dire tu es mon ami il cherche
la merde
tf6 j'ai très bien joué le jeu de mettre
en commun beaucoup et c'est quand même
dur de pareilles genre tour f3 s'est
pourtant vite joué tous les sécher
comment etc
qu est-ce que rick at il ajouté vers 3
ok c'est pas qu'il avait envie de je
sais il n'a peut-être pas le trouver
autre chose tu aurais kate voilà bien
joué türk a très bien joué surtout en
maintenant
l'on prend en fourchette et surtout rage
croyais adams et intermédiaires dont il
peut pas le faire ok là il est juste
complètement gagnant encore une fois la
domitienne s'arrête pour 30 gymnase et
abandons 2 cuil il a gagné bon wagon
business mais il a encore dominé facile
avec les draps stratégiquement très très
bien joué qu'elle est celle ses huit des
six as a rock roll sens et six des sept
pays sud ok il reprend le maire
d'ailleurs j'ai pas compris pour qu'il
allait arrêter tout ça parce qu'il était
mieux à chaque fois bon c'est pas non
plus beaucoup qu'elle est sinon ils
veulent du pasj et 6 passes joakim qui
te troll d'ailleurs sur le tchat
vasile écrit il est censé avoir
travaillé plus que moi les finales de
tour venant de cornetto ça peut désigner
n'importe qui non je suis pas connu pour
être un spécialiste de temps mais bon je
suis connu pour avoir une équipe de foot
le tfc connu par les crédits lille pour
le pape pour les finales ne trompe pas
ce soit cette chasse fc alors et on a
perdu un match terrible jeudi au père dé
5,6 et ré mi temps contre des bons jeux
deuxième du championnat et je me suis
blessé au début de deuxième a défini en
angola sans pouvoir bouger pour ces
friches et 102e
la tuile des gaules non mais non je suis
jamais golf c'est le seul truc et du
coup là comme je pouvais prix marché
qu'on avait pas de remplaçant le journal
le logo de la crise bon je pense que mon
équipe n'est content que je parle d'eux
bon là cette année on a trois victoires
c'est pas terrible on a perdu cinq six
matches mais bon il ya que des journées
chacun dans l'équipe
c'est pour ça qu'on est facilement c'est
qui votre meilleur joueur du coup bon il
ya un bon joueur d'échecs et non un
nouveau joueur laquelle judo match qui
est assez bon c'est mathieu la gueule je
pense tu connais son père qui est celui
qui m a joué quand j'étais petit on sait
que je connais pas et de le sénat le
prof de blé gamin de bordeaux et sinon
mazzei là c'est vraiment à il est solide
avec son cabaret de rugby
en faisant du tennis et du foot il
déménage joue un peu à la brandao
ouais il votre droit et les pointes
arrive c'est pas mal ça équipe au sénat
la juge julien favret nico le thé c'est
parce qu'ils connaissent en 2003 103-106
a continué l'été 2004 sont on a bientôt
kirk tu le resteras qu'il joue avec nous
ça reçois des messages sur la
conversation ils foutent que je leur
écris une dédicace on dirais ok donc
mais non à la partie tu sais qui c'est
raté pour un dernier truc hein tu va
rater quelques matchs à cause de la prod
casting tu as deux matches qui tombe le
jeudi c'est un peu la mauvaise nouvelle
en numéro 10 quand je regarde ouais mais
y en a deux qui tombe dès jeudi les deux
premiers matches c'est dès jeudi les
deux premiers matches non quand tu m'as
dit de 18 ans dit est vrai
de mémoire ça tombe un jeudi je peux pas
jouer assez chiant ça où tu m'avais dit
mercredi après après c'est que dès
mercredi après ce sera tout le temps que
des macros il ya que deux jeux d'id au
début on fait alors là on verra bien ce
que ça donne on verra au pire on a on a
on a du remplaçant quand même on a du
level mois ils jouent ils jouent tout
bien mais là du coup c'est pas avantage
hikaru dans cette position parce que le
pion ces chichis mais bon c'est pas non
plus pas en prison mais sur ferait bien
petit poucet 2 j'allais dire c'est que
c'est un tour franta vous prend à vii
est un peu mieux
mais en fait ça c'est des trucs tu
lisais dans les vieux bouquins que
c'était que tu gagnes avec les noirs le
pion faible machin tu le gagnes est en
fait en pratique ça se vérifie plus du
tout ce truc là bas c'est juste on
défend mieux genre timide amant f4 la
torah chis un jour qui j'ai envie de
faire un truc de ce torrent c'est
bizarre qu'il n'a plus jamais et achille
j'aime bien peut-être échangés derrière
ce qui peut prendre du pillon sur dame
premier fils se sont élevées à 5 46 kg 4
et bouffe espion c'est une idée ouais
c'est pas idiot mais on sait que c'est
difficile de trouver une alternative aux
séquelles en ses murs ne pas prendre
angers7
mais parce qu'ils ont regardé le match
du couloir peut-être à pense à son tour
d2 il faut bien prendre les 5 bien là je
vais tourner ne pouvait être un petit
problème
puis enfin agit donc là il parle même
pas du goût d'un met à peut-être faire
ces cinq permanents ou est ce que le
pion des quatre îles trop faible étude
prend tour b4 tombé 4 ça sort des 1 tu
peux défendre encore c'est capilotractée
même et tu peux aussi faire ses 6,1
d'ailleurs il faut aussi mais c'est
juste cette finale j'ai pas du tout
envie de la jouer avec les blancs ça va
aller bref 3 et attend et on s'éclate le
royaume
quand je sais pas qu'elle ait lieu
c'est pas non plus la mort c'est quand
même plus souvent on a cassé petite
petite finale avantageuse après un ouais
en fait c'est en gros c'est le scénario
ce soit car équipe domine grave car ces
gros milieu de jeu soit il se fait
appeler lentement et sûrement parce
qu'il sait pas quoi faire et clément
mais c'est un peu ce qu'on avait prévu
un genre les potions ok mais ici il sait
pas quoi faire il attend du coup se fait
dominer ok là tu peux prendre et 2,5
mais promet c'est pas mon genre je vais
prendre un peu dangereux nos deux ans
qu'il a pris il faut y aller 1-5 et là
il faut faire reprend je pense qu'on
prend un échec relève 6-3 f3 ça doit
fait tout reprend mais ça ça va se tenir
facilement puisque tu vas jamais obtenir
en corps gras dames 100 a perdu une
similaire il ya pas si longtemps mais
c'était étonnant santoni maintenant à la
musique la dame joue une finale 4 contre
3 le résultat est étonnant
c'était c'était étonnant et paris a
gagné 4 ans contrainte sinon ça
m'intéresse et qui intéresse donc il est
donc revenons à la pollution et tu peux
même craché quatre ans maintenant j'ai
quatre l'alliage 4 ce calme et kavokiva
pcf 5e cas peut-être et il va essayer de
jouer sur l'entrée du roi avait
normalement ça s'annule un mois le temps
derrière c'est bien joué en une tour en
1 8 comme ça il y aura jamais de trois
solides et dénoncer place et de 3,1 j'ai
l'impression que personne n'est capable
de jouer par parfaitement les finales le
tour des revues pour discuter un peu de
finale deux tours
je pense que t'as pas un joueur sur
terre qui est capable de dire je me
ferais jamais arnaquer tu vois un qui
est le tome 8 ici
quand j'ai eu à pama c'est notre façon
d'empêcher roi jacquard de chercher
comment il allait faire
je pense que maintenant ils bougent plus
simplement c'est ça et dès qu'il bouge
la tour et rage deux cités change le
pion lecomte le piolet ça devient facile
heures avec but change d'option
intéressés société des faits le 3 avec 3
4 ok moi j'ai un les nerfs wave 3 malin
malin je peux jouer tourgis ici sinon 5
15 à 5
ouais ça va se tenir ça mais bon encore
là ça va encore la faire ça me chante un
fardeau j'ai longtemps mais bon ça là
c'est une vraie nu le combat tu vas ces
différents corps et âmes et les coeurs
ou a dominé avec les noirs donc du coup
il est un petit prix avec les blondes
c'est parce que je l ai dit allez ni la
rue
bon il rejoue son système parce qu'il a
gagné à donna parti à vous on a versé
dans kalivas de mgf 3 pour changer un an
il reste dans son idée bon on dit on par
les cas où il ya eu quelques présents il
avance doucement mais sûrement vers les
bullet et ça va être intéressant
finalement devoir dans les refrains de
trois poisons du coup sauf que cette
fois ci le fou blanc et angers 4 suite
rappelle on avait une avec avec une
espèce symétrique en live là ils ont
changé complètement
oui mais c'est retombé dans le ser
tomber dans le système cols bleus trois
poisons quoi
ces 5 je regardais de notre chatte
hockey à 5
stratégiquement c'est encore normalement
tu aimes bien le faire avec le fourrage
deux parce que tu as besoin d'un raid la
question c'est est ce que les noirs
comme jouer b ou 5 saubesty sauver cinq
sont là et les noirs je veux pas garder
un statu quo sur la colonnade je suis
très content de ce conflit tu as donc le
four b2 est passé du mauvais côté tu
peux même jeu des camélias caps qu'après
prise prises pour remettre la caisse de
ça c'est typiquement le plan qu'on fait
dans le système de londres avec le
fourrage de bombay 2 ça me paraît un peu
bizarre parce que tu payes noir ce sont
bien ses sept tours à huit et tu vas
place et peut-être même 5 un jour en le
préparant bien ok faut se méfier des
fous prends mes cinq monts qui ne
marchent sans doute parce que je peux
prendre des quatre intermédiaires et
prendre un point dans dessins auxquels
échange du fou c'est un avantage encore
les noirs c'est quand même
ok mais les cavaliers à 5 redire tu as
tout fait pour jouer sur la colombie 5e
et la cia qui n'y va tout est changé il
va faire mieux ok les noms sont mieux 5
vas-y on va se quitter est ce qu'il
aurait pu échanger
d'abord non il a raison de garder les
tours peut-être un jour il aura foot
français cinq matches aujourd'hui mes
alliances et 4ème derrière de moi j'aime
ok mais là c'est pourquoi je préfère le
nombre je préfère les bleus aussi des
noms se dégagent sky ces trois là si la
faillite est dans un bon timing pour
l'eau cinq choses il aurait dû faire un
tifo des 8 pouces et 7
il aurait pu venir il y avait des coups
et il affirme je pense qu'il est pas mal
hein il faut que tu fasses faux abus de
foot et 7 et qui les changements
wesh pourrait en théorie je pense qu'il
peut tout faire
il n'y a pas de raison que ça aille pas
mais il faut se méfier un peu moi je
serais très énervé de vous retrouver
dans cette position en tout cas
t'as vu ta ville à terme cela il
s'énerve jamais s'en charge avec un
énorme tout le temps la même tête en
fait non en fait il a une tête
il en a pas deux en a une et d'échanger
les tours a changé qu'à imiter et
cavaliers c1 qui avait trois cavaliers à
5 mhz et attend de faire fou g7 fou
prend des quatre oui mais est-ce que les
blancs sont pas mieux non si oui c'est
pas non plus tu sais j'avais fait un
truc extraordinaire j'ai dû commentaires
un truc un peu similaire avec ap sol que
tu as peut-être vu une finale similaire
dans le match sodi riz c'était très très
difficile d'expliquer à elle seule ce
jour là le les finesses de la finale
c'est la première fois qu'ils commentent
et je me rappelle encore cette finale
c'est très peu mais qui avec apple que
tu connais un youtube heures qui fait
d'excellents de vidéos d'ailleurs
j'invite à périgueux regarder notamment
sur le dark web il a fait une super
série là qui est sorti a pas longtemps
libye mais en a parlé mais je vois tu
pourrais regarder un c'est vraiment bien
ce qu'il fait et on avait commenté une
finale un peu similaire dans l'esprit
c'était compliqué de lui expliquer les
faiblesses des pions et tout ça mais là
il va la tenir un qui l'a qu'elle ait
lieu si elle tenait resserré de court il
a très bien joué et ai même pas obligé
de faire ça prend des quatre maintenant
du coup je pense tu le fais pas même
mais attends ils vont peut-être faire
cavalier 5 icaro ouais mais c'est pas
quelqu'un en prison ne s'est pas
impunément et n'oublie pas que il faudra
vérifier qu'il faut prendre ça que tu
gagnes la finale ce qui est même pas sûr
genre je te jouer avec g5 après pourquoi
je perdrais cette finale d'options louis
nantua pas la perdre à chaque jour n'a
pas fait qu'elles sont l'idée c'est que
si tu fais quelques sens que je peux
prendre les clichés 5 qui joue pour
higuain 4 ou mais je dois te faire
[ __ ] si je prends les fous g7
aya plus qu'à réaliser 5 maintenant mais
j'aurais déjà j'aurais pris jusque là ok
mais ça il n'y a pas de raison que ça
soit pas nul mais attends à ce qu on
peut quand même faire mieux qu'elle a il
faut faire gaffe à ramener le roi en f3
que les 600 kg 5 g pas j'aurais peur de
la jouer quand même cette finale parce
que j'aurai absolue va faire un long
détour pour aller prendre j'ai un moment
donné qui a le roi qui peut j'ai pensé à
un sommet auquel rodez 2 je comprends
pas la lca vaillant d ok là cavalier ou
six parce que sur pied relief qu'as tu
fait cavalier prend la finale est nul il
n'y a plus d'accès nulle pa il va
refaire car les d4 maintenant son niveau
skype 4 ça après pions prend y avait
plus d'accès thé mais c'est fou qui les
boules bloqués sur 4 noir comme ça tu as
vu ce qu'il devait faire
il ya le faire dans le sens comme ça tu
mets tête ont pu manger sain comme ça
laurent blanc pas chez jamais c'était du
tout la même vague a purgé cinq et les
pillages trois points schiste ok il a
ironisé sur f3 il a des qualités à 6 mai
l'essonne il peut perdre mais il ya il
va y avoir réussi ses chais croit ses
7,7 il va avoir les qualités il peut
même jeu de crise et de quel principe
j'aurais pas joué six mois kéké réalisé
6 3 6 3 et 6 4
on va des 7 lacs et le saint cloud la
sauce calcul mais la paix sera aussi sur
ce que je veux et je cassais de un coup
au f4 nous revient des catéchèses hyper
bizarre a dit je vous pouvez juste jeu
là même à quatre en plus avec laurent et
je suis à toi vite il joue trop vite les
deux ailes et il repart de l'autre côté
c'est surréaliste encore puis je pars au
f4 parce que c'est le roi des 7 je
faisais 5 et d 3 à il a eu peur de roi
m6 et
j'attends statu quo et guen mais attend
est ce que je peux pas faire c'est
d'écouter côté classique
t'inquiète tu peux rien faire c'est
simple en fait faux vrais faux faux faux
touché un truc un moment donné mais oui
en gros on peut rien faire à temps mais
il veut faire roi des cas trois matchs
afin d'invoquer baisser les blancs qui
joue pour la gagne de toute façon
annoncé à sanaa mais l'impression qu'il
est gagnant parce qu en fait ouais
pourquoi j'aimerais clarifier ce qui la
f4 moment je pensais aux hells un
cavalier seul loin ce que je fais tu
perdais simple il va la perdre il le
fait mais je pense ça marche pas qui est
cette poule 3 bien joué elle pourra g4
qui avait lieu 5 et d 3 ces succès c'est
bien jouer comme ça on ne peut pas
prendre un b 4 ouais ok on voyait roi
g35 normalement ça va gagner ça ça il
veut jouer f5 projet 50 et donc c'est
comme il est malin il tente des trucs
queyroi h3 est la menthe et complètement
virois 3,5 direct je pense 4 3 4 dont
cavaillé chaque élève cinq oreilles tu
peut plus arrêter les deux pions
ah ok il veut peut-être joué f 6 km il
oscille celui-ci soit un petit peu pas
joué à vii jacquet jsa
c'est cette voie mais des deux as et 8
sur échec échec
c'était nul et ça fait deux fois qu'il
perd une finale nîmes
ça va commencer à se voir il a beau
dominer quelques-unes c'est un problème
que cela je n'étais pas si dur à
défendre sa limite c'était lui qui est
élu au début de mai non mais j'ai pas
trop compris la finale il s'est quand
même complètement trompé surtout
peut-être cavaliers 5 fera un gros même
nous on l'avait vu quoi ouais pas ce qui
est quand même gage de simplicité hockey
ici ça je connais bien ce peu sous les
jeux plus un choix le meilleur coup
c'est fou j'ai 4 x 4 et 17 es tu tombé
cet écart où il veut juger une pression
mais il passe un truc terrain il faut 10
islam est juste soit disant un tout
petit peu plus et réapprendre et blanc
d'ailleurs je voulais même pas sûr non
mais je pense que fin le match est serré
comme on l'avait prévu mais c'est quand
même le scénario c'est hikaru qui gagne
à la fin
ce que j'ai fait ok mais là je pense que
cela est très importante parce qu'un
thaler il a perdu une partie la guinée
celle d'après non ce qui dit pas de
bêtise ça serait bien qu'ils pensent à
refaire la même idée kata les émules
mais bon c'est ce qu'ont fait ces cinq
des 5
ces partis qui font penser si ce qui est
pour le 5ème plus merci je pense qu'il
va le prendre là le purement il calcule
des cinq aussi si jamais faim je vois
pas trop qui est ce qu'ils regardent au
d5 j'ai peur que les pions sont un peu
j'aurais moi je prendrais en saisissent
et je prendrai e51 quasi tempo en fait
après bon il était un peu de foot
quasiment chez
psychologiquement c'est 4 si jamais tu
pourras venir au cas où j'ai jamais
compris les mecs dans les chiottes qui
demande le score puisqu'il est partout
en face à côté des joueurs mais ça fait
déjà 40 matches qu'on demande à chaque
fois le score n'avoir pas remarqué je ne
réponds plus où je laisse les gens se
gérer balazé la cgt pas sur le chat
français j'étais sur le séparait de son
mari s'est séparé qui d'un tas de la b3
faut aussi sme sait pas donc ici un
petit nom maintenant les têtes c4 c4
j'ai peur non mais pas tout de suite pas
tout de suite pas toutefois qu'il était
trop peut même faire cavalier j'ai ici
c'est maintenant pour aller brûlures lol
non mais jamais à ces quatre
intermédiaires je le sentais depuis tout
à l'heure et peut-être santos après
c'est peut-être de la merde un sound
non ok je comprends ils voulaient pas se
prendre dans ces cas a laissé la foule à
guérir et e
au passage je suis pas du tout pour
quelques lignes je suis pour que le
match soit intéressant tient à préciser
lors des salons et des pour carrière qui
s'étend non mais je suis plutôt enfin je
m'en fous rires et surtout pour les 3g
france
non mais t'as le droit fin tu vois qu'il
faut des cistes en pense quoi
il faut des systèmes bien mathieu lebrun
ça va finalement au bout des 6 mai un an
peut-être non à m'asseoir schweppes que
hay adams ouais je vous dis ici c'était
pâques ou mais ils ont répété je dame 17
[Musique]
les blagues à nice pour le moment je
prends ça qu'il a joué ça d'ailleurs
c'est bon ça vaut pas tant d un ok ouais
m'enfin il a tenu la pologne
allez on y croit un putschiste non c'est
jamais bon faire gaffe à torun damache
grand barachois direct pour menacer matt
meilleure chose à ma droite ont eu lieu
à dame problèmes vitaux est pour le
moment mais mais j'étais en train de me
demander ce que je lui ai demandé ce qui
se passait surtout recettes d'activité
surtout prend un fils de fer damage 3
menacé le maté tu vois qu'il faut trop
ouais mais dame prend effet 3 et et
après tu les fais retour e4 turquie et
l'egypte représente un all-in des
prêtres des cinq tours france et 4 je
pensais que tu es nucléaires français
sont uniquement
je voulais mettre tours 8 alors au baoli
félidés sorte qu'ils perpétuent en avant
il faut des 6 août prochain sauf que a
l'air de marcher très très bien attend
il ya encore des me katz que surtout
reprend des cats à tour pris fuite
intermédiaire je vais donner demain ktef
5ème à 4,5 dame aux deux allers 11 ou un
recul adam munro achètes ton prend elle
chute d'un français cap à l'est
d'amsterdam 2 2 il ya aussi des tomes
j'ai six échecs qui peut vous m'avez
talent qui couve c'est un ouais mais de
nombreux tecan tu fais fou des six il
couvrira plus là me le prendre celle ci
fais pas ça il n'y a aucune chance de
guinée qui l'obligeait il va peut-être
la perdre
f5 dame eux deux je vois pas encore de
contrat ricains dorna sodeci s'en faut
bien comprendre que 5000 m2 importants
comme sarrois achète sept enfants et
fils
ouais mais tu menaces quoi au final
sous les 6 vous devez si je te fais
d'alger 6 c'est ça en fait je sais que
tu n'as rien pour le menace h trois
enfants et quatre arrivées du coup si tu
menaces
ben moi je comprends pas les ja plus
d'échecs sur la première et si il a
quand même tourné un ce que ça va dit de
se reprendre non non il va faire
il va faire ou arrachent un tour d un
d'un pronom des indes 1.86 est très
heureux donc c'est nul alors ouais mais
là maintenant est-ce que non il fait pas
mieux mais oui vous les faire tourner un
peu dévié de prendre huit super défense
super défense du chaos qui était encore
sous pression avec un point de moins
sanaa troisième jeu semble deviner sur
la tête de karuïa king comme une
première déception là là on commence ici
car on balance sa tête la whey 80 ans et
réseaux ainsi presque 13 à assad a fait
une mise de 3 comme ça est très très
très haut la barre est il alors est il
là il a vu king pendant qu'il ya des
écouteurs avec les régimes il écoutait
de la musique un do in mais sert de mai
karine aussi des ruelles et dehors on
écoute mais il a l'air d'avoir plus
heureux qu'il ait les nike les coûts de
beethoven et là tu sais ça serait bien
armand décalé votre playlist
je crois qu'ils le font de temps en
temps great il avait répondu je crois
que la veille et les coûts de quelque
chose de très calme pour les blitz parce
que c'est lent et ils écoutent du rap
pour les bullet parce que c'est rapide
mais tu as dont le pour great food en
fait les blitz c'est le cc l'an comme
cadence tu vois tu as beaucoup de temps
te retournes zite note
il a l'habitude
ok alors une stratégie en se marrant
c'est quand même on a souvent le même
type de pollution stratégique hyper
intéressant donc ils poussaient 5 il
échange de bons fous un icare ou sa
classique il s'affirme son mauvais goût
il adore faire ça donc la tshuapa est ce
que les noms vont arriver un scribe et
aop ou qui veulent essayer de faire re
sans que ça ressemble un peu à des
attaques panov d'ailleurs ce truc là dès
sa prise est ce parce que les blancs
sont mieux qu'à main
tu sens que tu veux que les blancs
soient mieux non non je veux que mon
optique t pour carrie acquis mais juste
enfin j'essaye d'être objectif
quand je reviens d'une collision après
je me trompe raison de faire un cavalier
g7 kf5 mais finalement le four b2 sera
utile parce qu'il protégera le pion une
surface et un pattern dans les partis il
adore avoir des mauvais points et 10
passes il adore ou alors c'est juste qui
comprend pas la position à 10 mais des
foules mais il fait quand même souvent
ça ok ainsi que h144 c'est bientôt 4g
cap les oreilles vous tu n'as plus
d'oreilles
l'arrêt de la fuite ou d'oreilles la
plus de cases de qualité cette île est
bien triste ces environnements
stratégiquement cette partie c'est hyper
intéressant c'est pêchu de [ __ ] alors on
a ça ça peut paraître simple ou
d'intéressant 26 comme super intéressant
ce qui se joue - la pente s'il ya une
domination mais qui est casé leucate ok
tu m'as donné tu as fait gkd c'est bien
votre ca ce pionner pas en prise que je
te bouffe à 7
est-ce qu'on va pas quand même intérêt a
encore une fois hyper intéressant est ce
que ceci se passe là est ce qu'on fait
b6 à la kids et on va arriver s'il de m
4la les noirs menace kébé vite rica et
c6 ok je pense qu'il doit gérer c5 c6
tué son fils de 6 ans mais bon je te
promenade
est-ce que je changeais une tour
probablement une fois de la tour et
apprécions pelé cette tourbe évident ça
c'est typique d'un truc un vrai talent
fou qui peut venir en des huit qui amena
sera ok là je te fais québec tuvalu un
singe de le prendre
quel ces six là ça va être mieux pour
les noirs du coup parce que le cavaliere
c6 il va être monstrueux mais il va
peut-être mettre juste france et 3 tu
avais peut-être utilisé son mauvais fond
pour défendre sa structure ouais mais
irait on le sait il va défendre dans
désarmés
mais le finirai ok c'est si son niveau
dans la gamme on voit qu'il ya un mois
je trouve un jeu coquin et kim contrôle
chez eux les échecs mais il est moins
mal un peu notre dès qu'il a une chance
de gagner il allait jamais pas c'est toi
moi là faut trouver un plan genre c'est
chiant que le cavalier suisse et je me
dis autant je peux le mettre en 8e après
t'as pas de casque m il faudrait le
matin m6 après ouais c'est ça le plan
alors c'est tour 7-8 sous bush qui élève
si ce qui inquiète pas facile mais je
non à quel point tu étais mieux avec les
noirs n'ont cessé d'afficher les noms en
jeu aucun mot et les blanches aucun
mauvais coup un ouais ouais mais genre
dont tu adores et questions fusent
éthique forte mieux mais genre est ce
que est ce que finalement c'est gagnable
et me vient jouer que ces deux noms à y
jouer c'est ce que quebecor est ici en
jeu qu'avaient les huit ce que j'avais
dit ça marchait pas bien ce qui avec et
b4 ont gardé la cage au sein d'ong la
ligue et section québec at il veut jouer
roy et sept îles cook regarde les blancs
vont prendre ces 6es ramener un deuxième
cavaliers en bts leurs plans après
falloir remobiliser chinois essayé de
pousser au centre sinon tu n'allais les
blancs sont
un plan de guerre semble pas ce que je
veux dire amener prendre ceci parce tout
reprend va bien qu'ayant des cats essayé
de faire c'est 600 jours dans le final
après bon les noises au mali vont jouer
wells est le cinquième il y aussi ce bon
par contre je vois pas comment on est on
est pas mal avec ça on est pas mal avec
lille on est pas mal avec les hommes et
mon je pense que les blancs sont bien
trop comment j'ai une idée pour 3 2 il a
joué un moment baykal investissent en
fout c'est un footing autour d'eux qui a
valu un cahier ce que j'avais dit avoir
toujours eu deux cas valeo 1 qui avait
des trois mois je voulais placer fou
prend un g5 petites peaux de banane
ouais ok mais quand tu vas faire qu'a eu
un qui a été 3 pour mes québec at on
peut même peut-être laissé la tour en
solitaire il va ramener le roi
il a une itt d'avant simple encore en
fait il fait rien il faut certes rouge
et 5e du talent mais bon voilà bien
jouer pour pas qu'ils prennent les deux
pions way pour tenir il va bien tenir
quoi qu'il est parti pour cailloux mais
pourquoi il a mis le fou ici mais tu
sais il ya aussi un truc pas mal à faire
de temps en temps c'est de faire pas mal
de coups qui servent à rien quand tu
domines tourner l'adversaire pour pâques
et pour masquer
c'est peut-être ce qu'il est en train de
faire mais là je comprends bien il fait
carrément qu'ils avaient des trois
bombes et 4 alors là il masque peut-être
un peu trop quoi non en fait c'est juste
qu'il veut être prêt pouvoir faire un
truc sur cinq
oui mais peut-être cinq maintenant quand
même ouais bah ouais c'est pour ça
qu'ils il a fait un truc certes mais pas
le truc le plus intelligente mais du
coup il quand tu vas faire français
secteur français 5 il va avoir à 5 ans
prise
il a mis la tour en d1 passe juste pas
il ya un truc qui va pas dans le top 20
mille ayila bien les mêmes qui à tour en
troisième ce serait mieux quoi le roi et
en f1 et ça j'ai pensé parce que les
bons pire je peux prendre de d'un tour
quelqu'un qui rentre là dedans c'est le
plus logique et peut-être c'est quand
même un peu dangereux tour décembre
prochain mais bon j'ai d'ailleurs si je
fais ah ouais d'accord mais qu ils
l'inspection en septième mais il reste
qu'un seul on n'aurait jamais fait ça
roule au long quel est ce que c'est que
cette merde
c'est ça notre jeu pour le 15 ans fait
son nid des cerveaux à chaque tour g8 ou
peut-être même pas en fait elle s'est
juste fait retour à 8h05 à quatre et ils
te dis qu'ils te laisse son curé qui
s'en fout total en fait mais attends
faut faire gaffe tout reprend g5 à cinq
copies ou bien comme tiroir à chisseaux
jours après ça se joue autant prêts quoi
de savoir si l'autre est temps de faire
h 4 h 5 puis on prend j'essaie à chaque
h4h ans je peux prendre en fait le seul
truc à tanger 8 maintenant du coup il a
gagné un temps avec sa manoeuvre
pas négligeable qui est devant les noirs
je pense aux alentours à 8 voire de
faire rage sept et il va s'en sortir
avec les où le show sur elle prend sur
la normale est à 8 pages est tombé deux
pour être si ce business très bien joué
à tour b2 il y avait tout ranger 6 il
faut se forcer reprend je suis et qui
vont fermer
je pense que si les mecs je veux pas et
tu forte rien tu peux pas faire part
peut-être parce qu'il est le roi qui
venge et 5 et 6 h his way mais il va y
avoir perpète non tout va maintenant
maintenant tu fais ok mais qui peut pas
nous il arrive à mettre le bouillon avec
rien c'est terrible et la nature
imparfaite ashes achèteront à 16,17 il
gagne un peu de temps je suis taxi soit
je sais c'est qu'il récupère créé le
pion et les menaces tour j'ai quatre
tours h quatre tours h5 quand même un
make a roulé à deux doigts de la gagner
c'était vraiment y avait rien au début
mais à un moment donné ont même pensé
qu'ils perdent un peu le contrôle et que
ça allait me mettre les noirs calibre et
peut-être contré quoi ce qu'il fera en
question achi siffert on achète
bien sûr ok il prend un nul
oui donc et bon parti hyper intéressante
en comtois il aime bien ils me sont fous
mauvais mais par contre à prix pousse
les pions et le fou move est il défend
tout ouais non celle de la partie du
très bon travail dans ces magnifiques
non là c'est des belles nul autant dans
le cinq plusieurs c'est un peu décevant
la lignée du faqih à de tarnac tu te
défends et tout c'est mieux mais il ya
plus deux pour n'a qu'à ça va être chaud
rien problèmes de connexion côté car
jaeckin et je sais pas s'il s'en rend
compte parce qu'à la caméra ils sont
fous total
comment que tu sais ça parce que cariat
qui n'y joue pas et que je vois la
caméra qu'il est toujours connecté à
internet
donc là c'est un problème de connexion
serveurs à trois points comme je sais
pas ce qui se passe dans ce cas là parce
que on voit bien que car yakine sa
connexion elle marche et il a perdu 40
secondes comme ça
un hacker faire drôle non ça joue à
lille a perdu 40 secondes
c'est ballot non puisqu'il a franchement
petit éclat stats en 15 secondes avec
l'humain un cavalier le 5 jamais jamais
vu du coup c'était pas compris mon
esprit rock
non mais en plus tu vois c'est pas du 40
secondes perdues sur un problème de
connexion ce qui serait son problème
c'est vraiment un problème de connexion
serveurs puisqu'on voit sa tête venir
oui plus comme on voit sa tête et qu'il
a internet sinon s'il ya une coupure
internet on l'aurait plus ok encore une
fois atypique fou prend entre quatre et
cinq aux quêtes ont foulé mauvais c'est
faux quand même sur mac à ce truc ça te
dire tu vas tu peux avoir que ça il
kiffe les mauvais fou mais bon sans
déconner si mon problème il faut arrêter
mais bon il s'en fout j'ai pas vraiment
il ay là je pense un vilain défaut sein
des fois dans son jeu vraiment d'amasser
5 10
allez il est quand même très mal ces
structures pour moi j'aurais jon hamm à
5 d'avoir pour éviter b6 d'ailleurs mais
les moyens même foot français non pour
française six ippons problème et il
prend à prendre ces 8es mais bon dame
prend à six reprises prise régler le
problème du tuf où elle d'am dam des
sept fenêtres façon la dame elle
ressortira au et adam croyait faisons
enfin le rendre ça j'avais pas du tout
vu mathieu on peut bon ok j'y fais
toujours mais à d'âpres ans et 6 x 6
haye il est chaud le quotidien
ok faut faire d'albert samain ça marche
ça marche pas il ya tout à un avion
cette fois choisi d'apprendre 6 6 3 6 3
ok il a égalisé du coup mais il en a
rien à [ __ ] c'est parce qu'il voit
bien la géométrie des attaques en fait
je sais pas il ya un truc spécial avec
ça et d'ailleurs il n'y avait pas foule
coincé si c'est le cas tout à l'heure où
était la tour on nous avait tant à 2,6
avait d'ailleurs c'est pour certains cas
il a changé donc aveuglement torvalds
tout le monde en plus parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup d'après truc hockey est ce qu
ici tour des indépendants pour des noms
d'emprunt ses cinq tours des limites je
prends et de maîtrise et de new york et
retour des 1 km2 nouveau tandem regarde
dames 7 5 tours des 8 me la d'un procès
vite et je vais retour à huit dames
c'est ça tu reviens non je fais tourner
un brin de tourner un tu fais tu auras
utilise des drones est un battant je
vais montrer la marée quand ça fait
vingt minutes que tape avant ce drame
non mais pas tout le temps parce que tu
vois c'est une direct aussi alors à
lowell moi je t'écris hockey du coup il
n'a pas osé prendre mais face à une
bonne tête pour les bleus non même si ok
par rapport à ce qu'on aurait pu avoir
tout à l'heure en tête faire bas et
errances et 6 ans et 6 mois ci ce fut
l'échec c'est la partie ok donc là tu es
mieux mais comment tu vas te faire
arnaquer c'est la question qui doit se
poser l'amd êtes inquiet mais qui
obligeait tour b1 soit pas trompé en bas
torah 5 c6 locqueltas lors d'attaqués du
mal à faire quelque chose avec les jeux
rois avec les normes et à lui procurer
cette sicav et se remplit si tu fais
faut aussi son touche à rien on fera
céder
moi je veux faire tomber en prochain
qu'importe on touche le fond rien je
pense
il est tombé six tombes à 7 alors si tu
fais le mort un très bon jeu fait clic
droit jesus de primes ou je te bouffe la
tour ok je pense que ça c'est un bon
goût ils pouvaient pas laisser j'ai
envie de te faire qu'est-ce qui s'il est
chiant naka là je pense que tourner un
clip que là il faut tout lasse prochain
coup cet ours c5 en fait qui menace ok
tu en penses quoi de à vous prend 1,6
prise tour d un tour ce cinq échecs 3 et
6 c'est un pouce il prend ses 4 mais ça
ça va aller la tour en dix-sept
normalement les mal placé mais ton roi
rentre pas je pense qu'elle est pas mal
classé du tout oran ne revient pas je
vais mettre le bon exercice peut-être
ouais mais comment ton rang revient il
fait que quatre
ok tu en prends la chaîne j'allais dire
du coup mais là il prend ses 6 1 sûr que
si tu faisais ce set il faisait h5 un
bien sûr oui oui suffisait c7 il faisait
achats qui a pris récupérer ses cartes
et le roi à monter mais là le problème
c'est que eelv a entendu une impasse et
la tour derrière le pion la toile et
jacques blanc - f3a tant que tu fasses
3f trois tours 3 f 3 e 3f trois rois des
trois est comme ça tu chassera j'aurais
dû faire retrouver la saq à tour de cas
qui est un g4 biographie il veut faire
h5
non il ne veut rien faire vivre trois
ans d'étroite reviendrait tout à l'heure
sauf que non ah il donne ce pion aux
caisses elle est encore mick théorique
g5 bien jouer on l'a re 7,1 je n'aurais
pas fait j'ai cinq mois il voulait faire
croire et 3 3 des trois et qui est un
bien je reçois ont rôdé chif
est-ce qu'on peut pas je fais un truc
avec tours g4 g5 comprend justice le
tanger catane est allé petit mais j'y
crois pas du tout il lui reste plus que
20 secondes un f4 à j'ai fait du tout je
n'ai pas du tout pensé que c'était un
coup légal aux qualités s'il promet à
tous at on réagi ramener le roi angers
et sylvie deux contre un
j'y crois pas du tout ce qu'il a il y
aura pour sa 3 entrez 4 un asocial roi
des rois des 3
ils voient des trois ses cinq tours c4
mettait tour sert à la c1 très bien vrai
parce que si on fait mais pourquoi pas
c'est simple sans prise tour à deux voix
tu peux pas faire co2 tco2 eyed peas qui
peut il peut pas prendre les rock cats a
h1n1 chaque fauteuil a lu la lettre et
qui pour quoi ils gagnent pas un roi des
qu'at-il fait de 5
et là c'est peut-être tout rêve du tour
m6 allait elle va faire les défend il va
faire tour à trois et on va tendre âge 3
pour quelle défense
ok on là tu veux plus gagné non temps
pointe qu'à trois detroit il fait les
échecs qui est le maître de tout ranger
sera ton tour j'ai besoin de faire trois
des quatre et ouais ouais les grosses
défenses encore mais il est passé pas
loin la abc ça fait c'est la quatrième
j'ai pas compris roi f5 genève autre
côté je suis allé de l'autre côté puis
vous revenir me cacher je sais pas ce
qu'il a fait et il fera date
il fixe les droits des trois maintenant
m brasse et 3e à détroit je serai plus
talent des trois oui il est complètement
fou l'écart est alors en b 3-1 fr3 b4g 6
et 6 j'essaie 3g si ce rallye comme
alain kerhervé 5 2 5 kgs fautif à 5 nom
signifie mais là il peut pas faire roi
des tours et chaque et roi des cinq
tours ait fuité roi des 5
non mais ça c'est gagnant donc pas ces
six aux trois toros temps huit amis
tombés trop [ __ ] c'est en millions oui
mais attends roi des six indices us roye
b 6 tours b 6 3 6 c'est le truc là
comment ils appellent ça roi à 6
maintenant tour à 6,3 b5 marois b5 et
surtour machin a brassé 4ème et nenad
milijas ion électrique très court c'est
cette sénart de fermer qui donc
mais oui c'est le truc que tu fais quand
à leroy qui est poupée ça mais là ça
marche parce que tu as eu tous ses pions
c'est chaud a donc là c'est la dernière
avant le début de sa il ya moins d'actes
maintien il tient mais au lieu d'être a
plus probablement au niveau des trois
pièces de fret à plusieurs il a moins
besoin et ça devrait être égalité là
dans le match ça devrait être limitée
complètement on n est bon s'il ne
réussit pas il ne réussit pas en
question
senna car en face moment là du coup
parti à la théorie mathieu dans cette
position j'étais mentalement c'est connu
elle a des remords g8 à manger un son
bien dès bénin tf3 nom en kurde avec les
airs quatre sachets vois que tu penses
avoir garé à bouger pour faire un geste
j'aurais bien hi5 là avec les légers
moins bien je fous ces deux grands la
tour en gironde j'ai envie de faire 5es
4es créneau pour mettre madame rage sept
à il attaque un plomb pas négligemment
air tran
9 38 ça développe la dame - quelque 4
c'est pas le bonheur mais j'aime pas du
tout comment jouer six en fait je cavale
est aussi un peu trop le choix oui un
phishing
il va pas leur chien je n'ai pas vécu
c'est dans ce jeu faut toujours faire
gaffe à elle peut avoir des idées très
bizarre car moi je serai bien fou au f4
et grand roque qu'emilio deux boutons de
m les empêcher de rock et en fait c'est
pour empêcher grand roque en fait je
vais faire fois jeudi vers moi grand
roque et des cinq bons goûts de nos
trois jours qu'elle a faut faire le
grand roque et des poussées mais poussé
d'étudiants qu'est ce que je fous le 4 x
4 des 5 quartier roc
je préfère les blancs je pense que les
deux près partout
non c'est pas ça les blancs mais bon ok
c'est pas non plus c'est pas à faire
peut-être cavani f4 et qui les fait a
dit va te prendre qu'un petit échec qui
va être poussé à 4 probablement mais
dans quel sens et ce qui bouge pas et ce
qui bouge sans cavalier ou deux une
bonne question ce qui joue prend dans ce
sens l'orage on a fait ce qui a quatre
un nom que les blancs sont tellement
plus rapide j'ai pas compris l'intérêt
de calais en quatre minutes
moi c'est pas non plus encore kata kata
haut il faut le prendre b4 quoi il y
aura place d'alger 6 je pense qu'il va
le faire maintenant moi je pense c'était
son idée de maintenant aller c'est le
moment de le faire s'il nous fait pas
lasser les créations d'objets six dames
e3 je suis d'un neutron trouver comment
un truc est brisée peut-être dam des
trois maintenant s'acquitter sur faut
prendre ce faire roy bessette en fait et
qui a aidé le kaki apriso trois prises
et placé à trois reprises f4 et
apprendra tout raid 5 et défunte a même
des fous bbc pascal a en fait eu force
qu'un échange notamment parce que le
caillou de emprise 3 et 7 mais là tu
fais comment pour éviter des changes
peut pas faire friser tu as pu tourner
jusqu'à celle et peut-être moi je viens
y faire
l'un d'eux est tombé 3 et 6 et 7
c'est en fait à food et six semaines
non c'est pas mal rasées si c'est bien
non mais ça c'est vraiment très bien
joué
ouais maintenant il va je me demande si
j'ai pas mieux maintenant et qui est
noir c'est ce ne serait pas complètement
impossible
on n'apprend pas toujours et laisser
aussi perso sergei a refusé la nulle
bassila un minimum d'ambition et de
jouer des six prises il faut prendre
mais je suis pas sûr que vraiment je
trouve pas en fait
mais je pense avec les blancs tu laisses
tu fais tour 3 il prend il veut prendre
du pew rendu fou il ya 500 en est sortie
encore un bon il a pas été ma très
longtemps mais il a probablement une
petite période qu'elle est là
normalement c'est la position ikaruga la
finale tant qu'un supporter qu'est ce
que la 4c une menace
m la tour en b2 mais je pense pas ok je
suis à 4 tours prend prise torbeck est
tombé huit c'était cool cool bien je
pense que c'était mieux tort h4 mais bon
il ay là il n'a pas du tout pensé non
mais ça va ya pas de raison non moins de
deux minutes quand 29 secondes 1 c'est
quand même mais qui s'échauffait avant
le halal food day qui a poussé son ex
plein blizzard sa tête 4 maintenant non
pour essayer le jeu avec quatre kilos
juste tout est changé il y en a ramené
le jamais facile pour les 4 pièces et
fou d'elle
asseyez il le fait bon un peu plus tard
fut moniz later ouais tu regardes y aura
10 h 3à il a reproposé nul ok il ya une
mini pas c'est ça ouais trois minutes ok
bon je reviens revient revient bon assez
chaud ce matin me reste on est combien
combien on est d'ailleurs tiens dites
moi dans le chatt convient combien de
spectateurs
combien sommes-nous à regarder ce match
il reste trente minutes c'est chaude
chez chaud franchement c'est un beau
match c'est serré c'est même très serré
on peut dire que c'est un match très
sympa à suivre
94 c'est pas mal c'est mark et moi je
regarde pas le pas le chat est c'est
pareil c'est pas mal verlan tours 2 500
c'est sympa tosh on va voir comment ça a
commencé a évolué en bullet mais
normalement quand même car ou de vrais
écarts ou devrait l'emporter
il est quand même beaucoup plus fort
mais bon après on sait jamais hein pas
déjà il joue plus vite surtout le match
donc il devrait être
il doit être favorisée quand même
hu va être plus fort en bus déjà il est
plus forts en bulles est de baser une
bonne réputation et où il joue plus vite
pendant tout le match donc il ya pas de
raisons pour lesquelles carré qu'il
devrait gagner le la section du let mais
bon qui sait tout peut arriver
sur le chat en anglais beaucoup disent
que c'est un record 2 nuls pour ce
tournoi
beaucoup de critiques en somme bon je
sais pas si wall est beaucoup de nuls
mais bon c'est des matches comme ça
c'est bien que les matches différents
aussi qui est des scénarios différents
je sais pas est ce que sur le chat
anglais il préférait les massacres
totale quand
quand il y avait quand les matches était
gagné par 15 points de différence face
un peu la question qu'on se pose là au
moins c'est serré on voulait un match
sérieux on a ratissé vrai il ya deux
points d'écart il va ce 30 minutes de
jeu rien n'est fait rien n'est fait donc
c'est un peu ce qu'on souhaitait
c'est un peu son souhaitait donc ne nous
plaignons pas et la finale normalement
ce sera début janvier
d'ailleurs il n'ya rien d'officiel
encore mais ça devrait être début
janvier
alors allez c'est reparti donc 4 de
karuïa qui me revient à une français
c'est la première fois qu'on voit la
française ou peut-être une méthode ruiz
on sait que qui peut faire qui peut
faire des méthodes rui sache pas si
s'appelle pas défense owen juste plus
comment s'appelle ce truc là et c'est
vrai que j'arrive à lille justement ça
or à 1h01 ouais c'est bien comme ça ça
s'appelle i là il a un répertoire
spécial pour le bullet hikaru toujours
il peux même te faire des méthodes ruiz
de failli te fais un peu de tout en fait
mais tandoori c'est une hip hop au tam
un souk aient pas mais je regarde les
vidéos temps c'est quand même
l'ouverture secrète quoi c'est la
méthode qui te permet de tout le temps
gagner aux échecs et android saad hassar
ne peut rien faire
bon pour l'instant il ya déjà 10
secondes c'est ma chance mais ça a quand
même puisqu'il joue c'est son machin
wayne ils égalisent à ses fins et
égalise pour icare ou dans les ports les
standards d'hikaru là une excellente
position sont fous n'est même pas
mauvais mois après majorité wang wei a
peut-être un cavalier ces six là qui
menace avec éprouvé cet échec
dès que tu as dit qu'il était bien il
dirait qu'il est moins bien avec l'état
et ces six là quand même
oui je vois pas ce que tu qu'ici cela
surprend 17 qui avait province est et
sur tourbe et 7 bat hockey des quatre
baies 5 aux siens mais il est moins bien
c'est à dire pas de vrai il est très mal
hikaru et du coup si cariat qui ne gagne
la première tu vois ça ça serait
vraiment cool
fous rires quatre noms ont gagné
matériel je te la [ __ ] 4 pour ces 8es
à 7 il ya là moi c'est tout pire dame
croise il donne la qualité d'un bon ok
mais tu prends et tu fais ok veut
s'activer comme un fou avec la dame en
f4 saissac et je te fais tour de 8 à 1
tour du tchad se faire d'un mètre 4 s'en
fout bien georges tron même s'il va
revenir en quatre et qui ce que tu fais
mais oui je veux pas d'un tour des 7e et
dames je trouve et surtout rêve 3 gagne
on a envie de les voir un truc mais
peut-être kg 3 la récupérer la calèche
mais c'est pas si simple parce que le
caillou c6 domine toujours la pause jean
rac41 kata satisfait jeudi autour des 8
mai à peut-être même la perdre
non mais incroyable hikaru quand il a
donné la qualité c'est fini car il y eu
qu'à ta meuf 4 il ya une seconde par
tous comme ça non mais tu peux rien
faire contre ça il veut la gagner en
plus facile un jeu 3d simple je te
prends un flou et 2 3 des cas les
montres que tu défends avec six secondes
enfin travailler 3g 4g si je 400 vols
l'éclaireur ge qui le fixent sur ta
couleur a pas mal il veut je baissais
ramener le roi et après alors cavaliers
hockey qui avale et messi sont son
discours
inquiet c'est le monde des pions lâche
certificats étrangers cavaliers franges
et 5 c'est bon ça doit être pareil sur
hk c'était vraiment h4 ok il me menace
cahier c6 de l'autre côté il va faire
une dame il va la sauver mais nos
cavaliers cavalières cinq échecs et
segment non hongrie attendait longtemps
bon ben je ne peux pas leur reprocher de
faire nul dans cette partie face aux
yeux je trouve pas les gens dans le chat
en anglais qui gueulent ya trop de nuls
fin qu'est ce qu'est ce que n'ont par
contre il y en a beaucoup c'est pourquoi
pas la compagnie il ya eu comme une
partie décisive 6,6 ou non il y en a
beaucoup mais bon il est vrai que dans
les 5 plus de il y avait beaucoup de
nuls un peu trop rapide ait manqué les
deux ils connaissent leur plein dans ses
schémas ajami 1,4 ça normalement ne le
faisais pas trop d'ailleurs
et je m'étais posé la question pourquoi
qui est des cinq allers voilà très bien
joué mais il se réveillera sévère si en
plus il se met à bien jouer on est mal
d'occasions a l'impression qu'ils jouent
mieux en bullet mais auguste c'est
sûrement parce que lui je voulais au
même niveau qui sont en bullet ou pas et
en face ça joue moins bien oui c'est
tout quoi là c'est très bien je prends
les blancs et 2 floor et i'm ok bon
l'autre on sait qu'il défend donc mort
de faim il a et aussi j'ai cinq est en
crise
donc je suis pas dans quel ordre mais
prise des prises de son on est fous
pendant et après 30 pg5 et puis après
engin avec pascal bessette est toujours
la même c'est s'arrêtant à raison qu'est
donc il peut pas prendre mes 3 et m6 la
marque a toujours le même cheminement
moi j'essaie souviendrai mais j'ai cinq
pays veulent enfermer damas cinq échecs
food et 5 maintenant une fois il faut
des cinq après tout qu il faut qu il
faut qu'ils ramènent la torche de la
tour eiffel qui a fait retour et 8
j'imagine qu'on tue des fonds en dame b
8 mars à part quelques alertes bien
jouer collectif et place faire cavalier
six heures après un moment donné et là
tu peux pas moi je voulais faire ça
j'aime pas trop je voudrais un homme des
six taureaux 5
ouais mais c'est difficile à organiser
non c'est peut-être ça sony le jeu de
mots cette tête dans ce sens la
meilleure adam prend 1,5
c'est pas facile de trouver des vues une
couche au classement tours dessin du
coup pascal fou avant est ok ok ça ça il
devrait la tenir mais bon ouais
facilement
ouais mais regrette le roi est fraîche
et 5 la g5 taille mais ok il veut passer
la tour
deuxièmement il s'en est rendu compte
rapidement et c'est bien parce à qui on
l'achète ça c'est un mot ça c'est bien
kelly à tanger cinq échecs ici ou là à
[ __ ] il enregistre intérêts
c'était gagnon tutelle mais c'était
finirait rouages de dames detroit il y
avait maté s'arrêter enfin d'amer 3
tours 4
ok il prêt à bouffer quête arrêter là
c'est pas nul
il a rapporté il s'est fait dominer
c'est qu'elle fait très dominés mais
bizarrement c'est hikaru qu'ils avaient
la peau de banane entre guillemets ça
gagne ok peut-être que ça gagne pas du
tout ce qui fut la dame et à une
forteresse me suis même pas sûr aïe aïe
aïe
forcément ça fait trois fois qu'il joue
sa ligne 3 fois les 90 pour un système
différent j'ai oublié de mettre le temps
malheureusement de je ne sais pas
exactement combien restent de tanger 23
minutes
j'étais petite coupure d'internet j'ai
pas pourquoi tu m'entends maintien des
mots ouais mais j'entends qu'il ya un
petit les pieds soubresauts peu
académique
ça peut être redémarré internet ça peut
être ça arrive de temps en temps
malheureusement avec les stream
le truc en semi difficulté mais à tête
se stabiliser et francis et aucune
ambition
h3 l'oreille car au dessus en ambulance
mais par contre on voit que il est là
quand même bien et qu'il n'y a toujours
que plus de mijas 20 minutes c'est ça en
gros même j'ai pas le temps exact j'ai
oublié de mettre au début de la de la
section mais en gros il reste il reste
vingt et quelques missiles contre un p
tit des coups mais bon tant qu'il reste
à -2 tu vois je suis en ambulance la
cité plus fort ses cinq amies pièce ses
singles une pièce au dos mais tu peux
pas ne pas l'arrêter choix dégâts c'est
quand même les consciences est rare à ce
niveau là à temps mais ça va annoncer ça
que marche plus il ya de la ville le
line j'y suis pas encore là mais pas la
tête j'ai pas vu mais il car je regarde
et non pas du tout les deux ils n'ont
pas du tout les sicav au salon du comte
dooku d'après ok cariat qu'il est mieux
maintenant ça me fout des cinq allers
les six gagnants
j'ai rarement vu hikaru autant déjouer
un an bull est 5e et son idée cette dé
6,3 c6 ou quoi quelle qu'elles coûtent
foule envoi de cette même es3 es6 soit
cinq noms tout bêtement
c'est super je tombais 6 les nazis avant
noël tron
au moment où tu disais que hikaru est au
dessus il a été séché après bon
qu'il montre qu'il est qui est là à
l'action d'une minute il est il est pas
aussi rapide qu'avant mais caron comme
on peut douter donc leila poussins il
reste 20 minutes c'est trop à sa fin
c'est chaud ce match c'est chaud au
moment où on pensait que c'était fini tu
vois non mais moi j'ai jamais pensé que
c'est fini parce que au niveau des
particules est quand même bien avec les
nuages pointent en fait il reste 19
minutes donc on va mettre deux brunes on
va mettre 18 minutes nous je viens de
récupérer le temps officiel va modifier
non mais on pensait qu'il avait pris le
dessus c'est ce que je voulais dire non
parce qu'il faille la tenue plus d'avant
les bulles est allé bullet qui démarre
bon car iachini la rater il a raté un
vol et tout ça enfin tu as je pensais
que le hold up était fait quoi à l'écart
ou proposent du tout aller car oui non
moi je te dis qu'il car ou en train de
craquer là mathieu est ce que tu me fait
confiance je le croise je te le dis aux
siens ouais mais je sais mais donc on
serait en effet mutuellement barroso il
y campe un tour f 3 3 qui arrive non
mais je sens au visage il en train de
craquer non en fait il n'a pas
l'habitude d'être hockey a pas confirmé
mais voilà il est en souffrance
le regard ils émergent a quel sens il
est même mal autant mathieu est ce que
tu as déjà vu hikaru avec 30 secondes
faut dire la vérité je regarde jamais
les blessures un traître que j'ai
rarement eu rien mais bon pain du coup
on avait quand même assez raison sur le
format du matin et que ça allait être
plus serré qu'en attend iliad un bien
car il s'est par abandon dam des trois
brigades ça marche la salle de la gagne
il doit y avoir un truc il ya peu de
bien la tâche 4 ch 4 h 4 h quatre jours
vite quand même temps éteint il avait
acheté trois maintenant puisque raflé
trois des enfants de variantes y aura
foule proche d'eux est interdit d un
d'un ff ou trois jeux non mais comment
tu vas mais si ça
au sam a fait ce qu'il a fait ce
gameplay 2d mais fois j'avais royal à
melle 5
c'est chaud match c'est chaud comment
ces shows ce match est gagné 1,5 m
quelle folie et la linguère ou s'est
rapproché d'un cran la fille il voyait
plus bien les techniques non mais
attends c'est juste le scénario le plus
inattendu possible quand même dans le
sens où on pensait car yakine démarrer
les bullet avec +1 +2 et que c'était
chaud alors en plus de ça c'est une
bonne ligne pour les noirs c'est une
bizarre de joseph blanc c'est pas bon
signe ça et là c'est sûr blonde jouait
pas de menace mais des trucs comme ça
l'avantagé que la guerre mais juste mais
bon on taille la russie l'a repris
sommes pas un truc tu as des gens qui
ont parié d'ailleurs sur ce match il
paraît que que bwin prenait des paris le
site anglais le bouquin car anglais est
vrai qu il ya des gens qui sont pas
contents ils ont parié naka est libre
bah oui
maintenant est-ce qu'on peut pas essayer
de ramener fo f5 tout rejetteront autour
de 3 c'était un peu débile c'est même
très con je pense pas je sors avec ou
non mais c'est très con est aussi ce que
j'allais dire c'est qu'ils tellement
bien autant je lirai soin d'un parent tu
prends les noirs mais toute ma vie vous
remettre un coeur en g3 n'en voit
l'échangé les changes
il est là pour ça et ça l'a en bullet en
plus évident à 5 face à saint quay blanc
je pense une proposition nul mais c'est
complètement ridicule de proposer nulle
a piqué convenu non non mais
sergei en déclin mais pourquoi tu
proposes tu vas sans leur domicile sont
donc il attend là il est quand même
caillage de la page ou un bon coup ça
fait un moment qu'on n'a pas joué à cinq
fois enfin le bon coup tours j'ai un tas
tenants d'un meneur d'hommes c'est un
ouais mais damien d'un projet de maths
quand même ce qui est un peu désagréable
pour ça peut-être tour g1 pour essayer
le message de ma femme qui me dit qu al
maqam écoute donc de faire un petit
coucou d'aidé spéciale dédicace j'espère
qu'elle est prête pour la prod châssis
bien parce qu'on compte sur l arrivée en
tête dans l'espace à me prendre ici
souffrent dans la crise
je sais pas mais peut-être une peau de
barrières étaient ouvertes
non moi non plus mais il va pas la tenir
celle là pourquoi pas puisque avec 4
secondes
il a amené ville oubliée le temps dans
cela mais là il a plus de temps je peux
pas défendre ça contribue avec si peu de
temps sur la pendule pas possible par
temps de crise il joue moins bien
1 voilà c est la fac
ouais ouais c'était le risque bon opus
impôts à carreaux mais bon il faut qu'il
fasse gaffe à ce titre alien un peu s'il
est mal de temps ça te laisser ville
j'aime bien quand il du jour sûr c'est
intéressant
j'ai l'impression d'apprendre quelque
chose ok cette fois il joue progrès
quatre normalement il ne faisait pas
trop on dit que les bookmakers sur la
section du lait tas et mika ou à 1,03
waouh
on va les mener sur le bullet les à
monza mais du coup tu en sueur site ami
si tu as mis ko pour les bullet 1,03
créera cycléa encore plus cela il lui
s'en fout ainsi peut finir la plus mal à
gagner deux matches il sera content
oui
on n'habitait pas très bien bon comme
honte - les bullet les coûts parce que
ça va vite et que donc et moi j'aime
bien les noirs dans cette pause mais je
comprends qu'on aime bien roulé blanc
aussi ça c'est tout le monde
tout reste à faire une phrase il faut
trouver un plan risque ont joué à cinq
de ses cinq balles et a joué à 4 c 5
pendant ces 3 il aime bien faire ce
concept rangs pour ce foin c'est son
kiff à lunas j'adore le fois je sais tu
tapes sur détroit le pion aux cinq qui
peut être fait j'adore les noirs ici
enfin j'adore on est d'accord jamais
l'accès à un moment il faut vous voilà
est-ce qui peut pas essayer de préparer
ces quatre pour la classe des trains
qu'il prend il va jouer
et pis si soudan qui est peut-être un
petit coup de km et 6 d'abord dame 17
d'accord ok enfin bien il joue les bons
coups les de qui veut gagner cette
finale
waouh c'est 2 sarah rien mais dans ces
jolis faut des gars aussi fou début de
fruits si ce qu'on peut remplacer
je pense pas qu'ils réussissent à la
gagner celle-là est la moins de temps il
avait notamment s'en fout de la cedh en
seconde
tant qu'ils la fassent cinq secondes ça
ok jour g7 je fais un petit coup de
tours c'était la capote musique à rennes
ou à la suite à tu veux dire avec tours
c'est cette poursuite à la musique
heures on à colin et j'avais fait le
test un championnat de france dans les
soirs l'allée des jeunes jardy capot une
caté normalement est essentiel à prendre
un coup les gens à 100 mg et qui savent
et il connaît la nouvelle génération ne
connaissez pas car dit-on pas différent
à 7,1
j'ai du coup j'ai dit regardez j'appelle
villes du cameroun zigani fois j'avais
demandé à gozo aussi savez mon lit c'est
manger à tout le monde de ses poteaux
mais bizarrement je sais je rêve de me
taper la honte sur un truc comme ça
j'aurais pas rater cinq mais là je
n'aurais jamais fait que ces quatre là
vous les quatre bien joué ils empêchent
les 6 7 ans et ce qui pouvait pas faire
assez trop intermédiaires et les espions
province ici pendant plus cinq
waouh
il n'ya pas quel point f non je vais
dire quel point f 5 e 6 au 7 mai non
mais au pire mais en échange non mais ça
a changé mais la cité sur de la colonne
fc dangereux dans ma ville à lui placé
tour h3 il va le contourner de l'autre
côté parce que le fou peut plus bouger
et comment qu atteindre un âge où se
trouve faussée cinq races et bien je
vais faire c'est beau aymen hayek et
blanc facile roi des trois-tours age 2
c'est fini tout finito les comédiens
pour celui des ados d'affilée ça fait
mal mais ça se joue à pas grand-chose ce
match a au final bas il est revenu à
égalité avec un lieu de la fin d'une
part entre 6 juin quand biden classique
à trois phases i à deux longueurs j'ai
l'habitude non non mais je suis en train
de me dire que ce niveau de jeu suffira
ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre contre 15
cents
ouais ok je pense le match comme il
était de très haut niveau il ya les
dernières finales oui le carl scène
nagai et je pense que dacca va mieux je
cette fin ça va être une belle finale
oui honnêtement c'est ce qu'on espérait
un c'est les deux meilleures de toute
façon voilà avec sur ce format là mais
du coup on apprend que quelques années
quand même vraiment pas loin ce qui est
une petite surprise
non mais en fait je pense que car yakine
tu fais là même devant un échiquier y
gagne le match en fait je pense quand
même que internet la petite différence
elle se fait ce choix tu vois ça change
pas des masses masse que tu sur un
échiquier sur internet mais je pense que
là la différence est tellement ténue qui
est mieux ici nos rangs la barre de fou
mais ils ont joué 5
j'avais envie de prendre les cages comme
un moment de prendre un f5 qui avait
trois bien joué je n'ose répondre hikaru
parce qu'il à 17 secondes de plus où ça
compte pas s'y ajoute pour la position
il est peut-être même mieux dans la
pression d'ailleurs tout cas c'est plus
actif à jouer c'est plus facile d'un
point de vue pratique la wii il est
peut-être mieux maintenant je suis plus
si sûr trop hein y'a pas de peau de
banane avec du fou décider s'ils
souhaitent mais c'est un échange
à tout prendre à trois là ouais pareil
ce qui saute aussi et j'ai eu peur de ça
mais n'en tint bon ça c'est nul
ok je prends des points blancs aïda joue
beaucoup ça si je me faisais tours 7
bon c'est vrai petit chien pourquoi ils
en attendent un gros volume
il a gagné 1 puis encore à 100 et qui va
je dois je boycotte cette façon il n'y a
pas de raison ne pas jouer le 3 compte
de l' as mais est ce que c'est si fort
dans les tons de 6 ans il est tombé six
tours j'ai six mois après il est ici un
truc c'est bien non mais là déjà il ya
des trois noms il pouvait pas jouer avec
4 de soissons il y aurait toujours eu la
case g4 je pense oui mais j'étais f4
jetteront je t'en faire le tour par la
case chaque bon après peut-être que j'ai
il a encore refusé nul c'est hikaru qui
a refusé mais peut-être qu'il veut faire
tourner la pendule comme avait fait gris
tout cas tu sens que le match est tendu
et tu fais tourner le puisque tu as il
reste combien de temps à jouer je dirais
six minutes à jouer
un monde six minutes à jouer s'il fait
tourner si fait tourner deux trois
minutes dans cette position c'est très
bien je sais très bien joué c'est tout
elle a raison de le faire ouais bah
après gritche lui a commencé à une demi
heure de la fin du match donc c'était un
peu relou contre kiel
c'était contre maxime on en pouvait plus
aux commentaires non mais j'étais vert
gens pouvaient rappel il est intéressant
aussi mais il avait bien joué incarne
dans ce match était au dessus donc et
dont la répétition
oui après ça empêche pas que que le gris
cube sur ce match là méritait la
victoire mais bon c'était un peu relou
mais après il avait dit de manière très
pragmatique s'était enfin voilà les
règles permettait de le faire et que
voilées l'utiliser les règles au maximum
tu vois du moment que ces réseaux risée
on peut pas lui question en cas
d'égalité pasqua
alors en cas d'égalité de mémoire ces
trois parties de départage 5 + 2/3 plus
deux ans plus un du coup s'il gagne ce
talent là il peut encore vibrer pour la
dernière ouais parce qu'il aura une
partie en 366 mais ouais enfin il en
reste encore deux ans un plus un don
qu'il peut encore vibrer même avec une
nulle en fait il n'est toujours pas
signé
pas dans le match vraiment jusqu'au bout
ok bon cette fois ils ont changé un peu
la façon de jouer est anglais bon mais
j'aime toujours les droits toujours
pareil le fou le 2 est moins bon je
trouve les sept
mais c'est pas si grave il va mettre le
foin f3 à b4 il faut prendre un témoin
bien peut-être là si tu prends la tour
et la castré 5
dans tous les cas yakassé 5t encore une
fois tu as vu mauvais fou tout le temps
actif tu fais quoi dans la vie et je
démolition genre si tu fais dame trombe
et 8 la finale 6-1 horreur non mais ça
contre carl cents a beau être nakamura
tu as c'est ça le problème contre call
scène de naka mais on regarde dans ce
match de l'évolution technique qui les a
plutôt bien joué qu'à la crise et juste
à moins king non il ya plein de peintre
là il a planté dans les bois alors là
ils en ont raté une qui gagne en un mois
il va il va sans doute faire mieux mais
je souhaite c'est qu'il a besoin de plus
il a déjà regagné depuis encore
ouais mais ça va faire ça à tout échange
et non ouais c'est la pl non plus été où
là il prend pas un pion mais ils
montrent qu'ils auraient ils essayent
mais bon il essaye un peu tard dans le
match en ratant du même coup maintenant
est peut-être kate fait son idée c'est
le bout faible ou la g5 et les lentilles
bonne idée c'est peut-être de manger un
moment et de bouffer des 5 1 jour pas de
oui je comprends ce que tu veux dire
c'est d'encaisser des cinq ans fait mais
je vois allied pouvait le faire au nom
il est rentré c'est le genre de truc
normalement il a perdu sa main il va
tomber mais bon il a craqué parce qu'il
devait gagner parce que voilà voilà ça
s'est joué dans les moments on va
rentrer car on a quand même montré que
dans il a les nerfs quand ils en perdent
de suite le match devient chaud il en
gagne 2 ce qu'il est en réalité est mort
il est quand même au dessus il est juste
au dessus du lot
non mais là c'est mathématiquement fini
je pense quasiment forêt qui gagne très
rapidement avec les blancs mais c'est
pas possible parce que hikaru il peut
laisser tourner la pendule de toute
façon puis du coup du coup le truc est
intéressant c'est je suis combat avant
la finale attendue quand même car cela
comment on sait quand c'est ou pas alors
il ya une date qui est pressenti tout
début janvier mais bonjour ni pas plus
parce qu'il a rien d'officiel donc c'est
comme pour nos recrues de pro-chasse
l'ictu voix tant que ce n'est pas
officiel officialise pas du coup pour ça
qu'on a pu officialiser maxime geneste
officiel mais ce qui est à 90% 95%
je préfère pas dire c'est qu'après les
gens le note et où tu en es tu en parles
1 pendant des plombes donc un métal
raison s'il sait pas officielle mais
normalement ce sera début janvier après
quelle date exacte
mais début janvier vrai parce qu'en fait
ils veulent ils veulent que ça se
termine avant le début de la prochaine
cible justement vu qu'on parle un peu
pro che sling parce que pro-chasse hic
c'est que ça de sa est en train de
devenir un très gros truc hein sans
rigoler ouais mais bon essayer de faire
bonne figure parce qu'on peut environ
fait mauvaise figure tu vois pour qui il
est en train de faire est d'essayer de
le mater nains je pense qu'il va réussir
non effet une mauvaise dette baiia et je
croyais juste pas de match donc même les
gens de maths et quand il est pas de
même au pire il est en train de
s'assurer la victoire du match juste
sans tournant même s'il perd du coup
bien jusqu'où derrière ok mais la finale
n'est pas mieux pour les blancs et du
coup il pourra regretter quand même
sergei a les occasions ratées dans l'est
dans les cas dans son rôle 4 les trois
mêmes droits ouais parce qu en bullet il
n'était pas si on dessous de sa voix ses
caisses ok mais jour e3 quand même à
émettre le cavalier en v3 et faire un
pion passé
pas si cons ok mélo tibia droit est-ce
que je peux pas jouer cavalier fin qui
des deux oui à quelle c3 et c3 j'aurais
eu peur de nos trottoirs
je le ferai jamais je pense qui s'est
hissée raviser oui mais enfin quel aussi
ce que tu dis ouais ouais bah c'est le
grand jeu pour le bien et après tu
prends ces 5
et tu crois qu'ils avaient trois échecs
trois des quatre années d'âpres et f3 ou
trois je fais quelques captures écran
tout le monde après j'ai manqué de jus
bien rodée cut
parce que là qu'ils avaient trois des
quatre c'est quand même violent c'est
fou j'ai six qui avaient trois des
quatre il est obligé de gaza et
maintenant peut-être fou geste mais
quand même il ya ma jouer il fallait
jouer le cadre d'abord ouais mais
maintenant que tu as ta mère
maintenant on sait que tu bouges plus
pour à detroit
alors ça c'est bien je n'en sais bien
j'aime ça
on ne sait pas bien joué qu'elle et ses
plus beaux on panique il est en panique
même ils assurent les records même sur
la caméra il n'a pas sombré comme
d'autres préfèrent qu'il est je crois ça
fait trois fois refusée si hockey fait
trois quatre cinq ou six endroits f4
alors un f4 tu la perds après royal 90 3
c'est un truc sportif ou là où la queen
berne
ok point f3 et non mais ça marchait pas
qu'ils apprennent ce rallye et ses bons
plans je n'ose advenant la dernière non
mais ça s'est joué à rennes
bizarrement ça c'est pas juste dans les
lettres ces jeux vraiment avant quand il
y aura des occasions entreprise de forme
et ça c'est un peu joué au début de
match l'an 5 + 2 quand il gagne la
première quand il gagne la deuxième
équipe r2 d'affilée
une date qu'il aurait essayé plus serré
le jeu ou quoi mais ça se joue à rien
mature normal y est au dessus il est au
dessus mais il n'y a pas non plus il
peut pas les fous processing et n'a pu
mais il veut pas ça ne l'intéresse pas
non mais c'est dangereux de le prendre
mais peut-être que tu pouvais pas ce qui
peut les prendre une option qui est des
cinq et ces deux dom siens
choqués les new way sympa sympa sympa